Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 105 und diese Ausgabe hat mich jetzt mal wieder außerhalb von Berlin geführt, eine längere Zugreise in die Stadt Oldenburg, in Oldenburg, wie man so schön sagt und wie man dann auch immer zweimal eingeben muss, wenn man Online-Tickets bucht und so was, dann man auch genau weiß, welches Oldenburg hier gemeint ist. Ja, und warum bin ich hier? Ich bin hier, um Felix Kronlage aufzusuchen. Hallo Felix. Wieder einmal so ein Podcast, der schon seit Jahrzehnten geplant ist und irgendwie nicht so richtig in die Spur kam. Mangelstelfinverpeilung.
Echt, wirklich?
Oh weia. Naja, aber das Thema ist ja nach wie vor ein aktuelles, ein Dauerbrenner sozusagen. Und zwar sollte es heute gehen um OpenBSD, das Betriebssystem OpenBSD, wo du, Felix, ja nun schon ziemlich lange mit zu tun hast, oder? Seit wann denn eigentlich?
Also damit begonnen mich für OpenBSD zu interessieren, habe ich 99 und orbitiere seitdem auch um die Gruppe der OpenBSD-Leute, insbesondere Wim, den ja nun glaube ich viele kennen.
Wim van der Putte, der in Belgien, sozusagen der KD85 und OpenBSD-Merchandise in Europa sozusagen. Genau, immer präsent, vielen bekannt, die vor allem auf CCC-Veranstaltungen rumgammeln, aber auch auf anderen, eigentlich auf fast jeder Konferenz, die sich irgendwie in Mitteleuropa anbietet.
Richtig, was auch der Grund ist, warum es so viele europäische Entwickler gibt, meine ich, für OpenBSD. Eben weil Wim überall präsent ist und auch die Leute zieht.
Ja, er verbreitet immer gute Laune und bringt sich ja auch wirklich auf eine sehr besondere Art und Weise ein in der Community.
Richtig und immer mit dem Punkt.
Ja, da gibt es aber ja eh so eine spezielle Feierlaune in der OpenBSD-Community, da werden wir noch drauf zu sprechen kommen. Vielleicht zum Einstieg noch mal so ein mal so ein bisschen hinterfragen, was so dein Hintergrund ist. Ich meine, wenn du jetzt seit 99 sagst, du hast ja fast zehnjähriges Jubiläum.
Naja, ich orbitiere seit 99 rum. So richtig OpenBSD-Entwickler bin ich seit 2006, 2005 irgendwie sowas. Aber im Prinzip bin ich auf dem Linux-Tag, 1998 glaube ich, wir haben das erste Mal begegnet und habe da irgendwie den Stand gesehen und habe mir eigentlich das CD-Set mitgenommen, weil ich das Artwork, das CD-Artwork so spannend fand, was halt schon sehr rausstechend war. Und habe gedacht, Mensch, das sieht aber cool aus irgendwie und nimmst mal mit und probierst es aus.
Das sind diese wunderbaren bunten Poster.
Poster, Aufkleber und aber halt auch das ganze CD-Set ist halt schon von Anfang an ja immer sehr gestylt gewesen, also irgendwie in ein Booklet mit Comic und...
Wer macht das eigentlich, dieses Styling?
Dafür verantwortlich ist Ty, das ist ein Freund von Theo in Kanada und Ty ist Musiker, Grafiker und Künstler und entwirft halt für jeden Release halt das... Das Motto kommt wohl von Theo unter Rücksprache mit ein paar Entwicklern und dann übergibt er das Ty und Ty macht daraus halt so das finale Produkt und macht ja auch für jeden Release mittlerweile einen Song. Also ich glaube, das hat angefangen...
Einen Song?
Ja, ich glaube, das hat mit 3.0 angefangen. Ich glaube, 3.0 war der erste Release, der das hatte. Und seitdem gibt es ja auf in jedem CD-Set von OpenBSD, also alle halbe Jahr gibt es ja 3 CDs normalerweise, und auf einer ist ein Audiotrack. Und es gibt sogar eine Jubiläum-CD, wo ich meine 10 Lieder drauf sind. Also es gibt eine Audio-CD von OpenBSD.
Was ist denn das dann für Musik?
Auch das ist unterschiedlich. Ich glaube, die erste Variante war wirklich ein relativ so Hardcore-Techno-Song und dann ging es weiter. Und es gibt mittlerweile alle Varianten. Also es gab halt dann irgendwie mal eine Humpa-Fassung. Das haben wir tatsächlich irgendwann mal gemacht. Und dann gab es einen Release mit Puffy Hood. Also in Anlehnung an Robin Hood gab es eine mit Puffy Hood. Und das war dann auch mit Männergesang im Hintergrund und all sowas. Also es gibt jedes Mal wirklich was anderes. Und das ist halt auch das, was so dieses E-Typ mal wieder ist, dass es einfach Spaß macht, dabei zu sein. Weil man hat halt nicht nur ein Betriebssystem, sondern man kann, und das ist auch so ein Verkaufsfaktor, weil die CD ist halt so ein bisschen so ein Fan-Artikel. Man kann sich schön hinstellen, man hat aber auch so ein bisschen, man hat eine Geschichte dazu. Zu jedem Release gibt es eine Geschichte, ein Motto, was sich halt mit durchaus auch politischen Themen in der Software-Szene auseinandersetzt. Also es gab ja mal den Cisco-Patent-Streit, VRP, also das ist ein Redonanzprotokoll von Cisco. Und da hat Cisco Patent Anspruch drauf, und OpenBSD hat ja einen patentfreien Equivalent entwickelt, CARB, Common Address Redundancy Protocol.
Worum geht es bei diesem Protokoll?
Letztendlich hast du zwei Firewalls, und die sind im Redonanzverband und tauschen ihre States aus. Und wenn die eine auswirkt, übernimmt transparent die andere.
Okay, und das wollte sich Cisco patentieren lassen?
Nein, Cisco hat das patentiert. Es nennt sich VRP bei Cisco. Und es gibt halt einen freien Pendant dazu, und das ist das, was OpenBSD mit CARB macht. Und dazu gibt es halt auch eine Geschichte. Und das war halt auch Motto von einem Release. Wie geht die Geschichte? Das war halt, also das war eine Anspielung. Also das Lied dazu ist dann auch eine Anlehnung an diese Monty-Python-Geschichte. Und da kommt halt ein Fisch, glaube ich, in den Laden oder irgendwie sowas. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau. Es ist auch schon ein bisschen her.
So mein Luftkissenfahrzeug ist voller Ahle bliesse ich über mich.
Und auf jeden Fall unterhalten die beiden. Und das ist, oder der eine kommt ins Patentamt und redet mit dem Patentmenschen und sagt, er möchte gerne was anmelden. Und der meint, aber das können sie gar nicht anmelden. Und also, naja, so eine Geschichte.
Kommt ein Fisch ins Patentamt. Dieser Fisch, der ist ja das hervorstechende Logo von OpenBSD. Was ist das eigentlich so rein von der offiziellen Klassifizierung?
Ein Kugelfisch natürlich.
Ein Kugelfisch.
Ist doch klar, oder? Blowfish, der Algorithmus, Blowfish?
Darauf bezieht sich das?
So meine Vermutung. Also ich habe es nie richtig hinterfragt, weil es eigentlich so klar ist. Weil es ist halt ein Kugelfisch und damit ist Blowfish und damit der Algorithmus gemeint. Ich glaube, es gibt dazu auch einen Hintergrund, aber da bin ich ziemlich schwach und deswegen lassen wir das mal lieber.
Also ich muss sagen, ich habe eine andere Assoziation immer damit gehabt, weil dieser Fisch ja sozusagen so …Aufgebläht ist? Das hast du gesagt. Nein, nein, aber wenn er sich halt so aufbläst mit all diesen Stacheln, das verkörpert für mich immer diesen Security-Gedanken. Und das ist ja auch immer so das erste Wort, was einem eigentlich einfällt, wenn man an OpenBSD denkt. Also zumindest das erste, was mir einfällt, wenn ich an OpenBSD denke. Einfach so dieses irgendwie, und in diesen Grafiken, in diesen Postern ist er ja dann häufig auch irgendwie schwer bewaffnet und so weiter. Also das ist auf jeden Fall ein ganz deutliches Merkmal, dass das da so eine große Rolle spielt, wenn man da jetzt zu NetBSD oder so schaut. Da ist das gar nicht so stark. Linux hat natürlich mit seinem Pinguin auch so ein bisschen so sein Ding.
Der übrigens auch sehr fett ist, aber...
So wollte Linus Torwalz das auch. Er wollte ihn fett und gemütlich haben. Auch im Osat-Wirken. Das ist ihm, glaube ich, auch gelungen. Ich weiß nicht, was das ausdrücken soll, aber gut, bei dem Fisch... Ich sehe halt immer so die Wehrhaftigkeit, aber das ist jetzt auch nur meine eigene Interpretation. Aber klar, Krypto spielt auch eine Rolle. OpenBSD ist natürlich vor allem bekannt für... OpenSSH und damit sozusagen ja auch so das Poster-Child der Security schlechthin. Also ich meine, wenn irgendjemand mal irgendein Tool benutzt hat, was mit OpenBSD in Verbindung ist, dann ist es definitiv erst mal SSH und danach kommen die anderen Sachen.
Ich meine, wer arbeitet denn ernsthaft in der Unix-Umgebung ohne SSH-Einsatz? Niemand. Und wenn man SSH mittlerweile einsetzt, setzt man einfach OpenSH ein. Das ist einfach auf jedem System mittlerweile standardmäßig eigentlich dabei und vorhanden. Und es ist einfach... Ich denke mal, es ist auch eine Sache, die können sich Theo und Konsorten einfach sehr auf die Fahne schreiben, dass sie eben halt OpenSS und OpenBSD auch so etabliert haben damit.
Ja, jetzt muss man es vielleicht auch nochmal erklären, ein paar Mal schon ist es gefallen. Theo, Theo de Raad, eine äußerst polarisierende Persönlichkeit, das trifft es glaube ich ganz gut. Welche Rolle spielt er in dem Projekt?
Er ist Chef. Also das ist erstmal so glaube ich eine sehr simple Art zu sagen, aber es ist halt Theos Projekt. Also Theo hat es gegründet und so sieht es Theo auch, also es ist halt sein Projekt.
Woraus ist OpenBSD entstanden?
OpenBSD ist ein Fork von NetBSD. Theo ist, ich meine es war 95, im Streit mit den NetBSD-Entwicklern auseinandergegangen und hat halt dann gesagt, gut, dann ist es so.
Warum drehte sich dieser Streit?
Das kann man nachlesen, also ich möchte da gar nicht so weiter drauf eingehen, weil es ist auch nicht mal ein Bier, aber es gab auch ein öffentliches Archiv davon, von den Mails, die kann man glaube ich über Theos Seite erreichen. Also wenn man so ein bisschen googelt, findet man sich das Mail-Archiv. Also Theo hat irgendwann die M-Box veröffentlicht mit den Mails, die zwischen ihm und den NetBSD-Entwicklern dann hin und her ging. Das kann man im Detail nachlesen, wenn man sich dafür interessiert.
Alles klar, gut.
Ich glaube, es ging grob auch um die Art, die Theo manchmal hat. Aber das ist so, ich habe es vor ein paar Jahren mir mal irgendwann durchgelesen, ich glaube, das war irgendwie 2002 oder so, dass ich mir das M-Box Archiv mal halb durchgelesen habe.
Wie ist denn seine Art?
Er ist halt schon fordernd von den Entwicklern, also er fordert schon was von den Entwicklern. Entweder man ist Entwickler und man bringt auch etwas dazu bei zu dem Projekt oder man ist ja kein Entwickler. Und da fordert er schon, was er schon auch fordert von Entwicklern, ist, dass sie nachdenken und dass sie Qualitäterzeugung und eben nicht BIM-Biss. Und das ist denke ich mal eine Position, die kann man sehr verstehen. Weil das ist auch etwas, wenn ich mir sage, ich habe hier einen Betriebssthema, das habe ich maßgeblich mit aufgebaut, dann möchte ich halt sicherstellen, dass das auch ordentlich bleibt. Und das ist halt das, was Theo macht. Er hat, denke ich mal sicherlich, und das wissen alle, die ihn öffentlich mal erlebt haben, auch manchmal auf Mail-Listen durchaus eine Art, die nicht ganz so der gute Ton ist. Ich glaube so, ja, ich meine seine Wortwahl ist einfach nicht passend.
Er ist sehr direkt.
Und er hat, glaube ich, auch da eine Umgangsweise manchmal mit Menschen, die, ist nicht jedermann Sachen. Aber auf der anderen Seite muss man auch einfach sagen, Theo hat einfach von dem, was er macht, eine Menge Plan. Also wenn man sich anguckt, wie lange Theo dabei ist und wo er schon mal überall seine Nase drin hatte und wo er herkommt. Also ich meine, Theo hat einfach maßgeblichen Plan von den Sachen, die er macht. Und er ist einfach ganz klar auch auf dem Gebiet eine Autorität. Und das, was er versucht, mit OpenBSD ein freies, unixoides Betriebssystem herzustellen, das hat er geschafft. Und OpenBSD ist, wenn ich mir angucke, womit ich tagtäglich arbeite und wir setzen auf Arbeit massiv OpenBSD ein, ist es genau das, was ich brauche für meine Arbeit. Also ich setze jetzt irgendwie seit sechs Jahren OpenBSD kommerziell ein. Wir verkaufen Sachen mit OpenBSD, wir verkaufen Dienstleistungen unter OpenBSD und nicht umsonst bin ich dabei geblieben. Nicht umsonst sage ich nach wie vor zu meinen Kunden, das ist genau das, was wir an dieser Stelle brauchen. Das ist sicherlich nicht perfekt für jedermanns Sache, auch nicht perfekt für jeden Zweck, aber das richtige Werkzeug hat schon einen richtigen Zweck und da hat Theo genau mit dem Team das geschafft. Und das, was er schafft, ist, dass durch die Art, wie OpenBSD funktioniert, das Ganze ein sehr homogenes Produkt ist. Es ist sehr gradlinig, es ist sehr homogen und es macht zum Beispiel für mich sehr viel Spaß damit zu arbeiten, weil es einfach sehr aus einem Guss ist. Und das kann man aber sicherlich nur, wenn man auch manchmal sehr hart und einschneidend sagt, wo es langgeht.
Diese Homogenität ist ja eigentlich auch ein Merkmal aller BSD-Varianten. Also wer jetzt mit dieser ganzen BSD-Welt nicht so vertraut ist, ich habe ja bei CRE auch schon mal darüber gesprochen, da ging es primär um FreeBSD, wollte jetzt aber auch bewusst auch diesen Fokus OpenBSD mal aufmachen, aber man hat es jetzt heutzutage vor allem neben dieser ganzen Linux-Wolke im Open-Source-Bereich eben mit der BSD-Wolke zu tun. Und die BSD-Wolke besteht im Kern aus FreeBSD, OpenBSD und NetBSD.
Und ich denke mal, fairerweise kann man mittlerweile Dragonfly hinzuziehen.
Hat das schon so Dynamik entwickelt?
Es hat insofern Dynamik entwickelt, dass es Treiber gibt, die von FreeBSD zum Beispiel nach Dragonfly portiert werden und dann von Dragonfly zu OpenBSD portiert werden. Das heißt also auch OpenBSD-Entwickler portieren Treiber nach OpenBSD von Dragonfly. Und insofern denke ich mal schon, dass es genug Relevanz hat. Weil sonst würden, wenn es keine Relevanz hätte, würden nicht OpenBSD-Entwickler beigehen und von dort Treiber nehmen, um sie zu uns zu portieren. Also würde ich jetzt so für mich sagen, von daher hat es genug Relevanz. Also es mag sicherlich noch kein System sein, was ich zum Beispiel produktiv für mich einsetzen würde. Dafür hat es auch genug Experimentalsachen. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine Quelle, wo man sich bedienen kann im Rahmen der BSD-Lizenz und das ist natürlich klasse. Und dafür hat es Relevanz.
Ja, also so ein Code-Austausch zwischen den Systemen ist ja eigentlich üblich, oder?
Ja, richtig. Also es ist halt, also die einen nennen es die Kupfern von uns, die anderen nennen es ein Geben und Nehmen. Also wenn du dir anguckst, wie so der Treiberweg häufig ist, also ein BSD schreibt einen Treiber, dann guckt sich das andere ein bisschen, hm, können wir übernehmen, nehmen halt den Teil, den sie brauchen. Es geht nicht bei jedem Treiber, weil natürlich verschiedene Schnittstellen natürlich über die Jahre auch weiter voneinander divergiert sind. Aber zum Beispiel gerade beim USB-Bereich gab es lange Zeit wirklich einen sehr guten Austausch. Also wenn du dir jetzt, und das ist tatsächlich der Teil, wo ich bei OpenBSD, wenn ich wirklich aktiv bin, aktiv bin, war ja 3G, also UMTS-Support. Und da gibt es halt eine Menge Treiber, die einfach in allen vorhanden sind. In allen drei BSDs und wo ich natürlich auch regelmäßig, ich gucke halt regelmäßig, ok, welche Device-IDs, also für neue Chips, fügt der NetBSD hinzu. Kann ich die auch bei uns hinzufügen. Genau so gucken die bei uns. Also ich diskutiere auch auf der FreeBSD-USB-Liste manchmal mit, weil da sind halt Teile, die interessieren mich auch bei OpenBSD. Das heißt, da lese ich auch die FreeBSD-Mailing-Listen. Und da kann ich dann auch, da findet einfach ein Austausch statt. Und man kann es natürlich immer als Konkurrenz sehen. Und man kann auch natürlich dann himmlisch sagen, ha ha ha, jetzt ist NetBSD wieder so arm, die mussten wieder einen Treiber von uns nehmen. Aber man kann es so einfach als Code-Austausch sehen und als einfachen geben und nehmen in der Szene, denke ich mal.
Aber das beschränkt sich jetzt aber auch nicht nur auf Treiber, oder?
Nö, auf alles Mögliche.
Man schaut sich auch so an, was die anderen architekturell sich so ausdenken.
Ja, sicherlich. Aber das ist halt so ein Teil, wo ich zum Beispiel nicht genau weiß, wie viel unsere File-Systementwickler, die wir haben, bzw. die ein, zwei, die wir haben, tatsächlich zum Beispiel gucken, was es in anderen gibt. Also ich denke, bei UFS 2 wurde nach OpenBSD portiert. Das kam, denke ich mal, größtenteils von FreeBSD. Das hat ja Pedro aus Brasilien hauptsächlich gemacht. Mittlerweile hat Otto bei den User-Land-Tools viel geholfen. Otto kommt aus den Niederlanden. Übrigens der, der auch BSD und, ich meine, DC als BSD-Variante neu geschrieben hat. Er hat sich da auch sehr verdient gemacht.
Den Business Calculator und den Desktop Calculator?
Ich muss zugeben, und das ist leider so ein bisschen eine Armutzeugung. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wofür BSD und DC steht. Aber da habe ich jetzt im Prinzip auch schon einen Punkt angesprochen, was wir tatsächlich machen bei OpenBSD ist, dass wir tatsächlich versuchen, Tools, die wir im User-Land haben, durch BSD-Variante zu ersetzen, weil wir ein BSD-Betriebssystem anstreben. Also ein Betriebssystem, was komplett unter der BSD-Lizenz veröffentlicht wird und womöglich wenig GPL oder solche Bestandteile drin sind.
Warum?
Da muss ich es leider ein bisschen wieder auf meinen Kommerzhintergrund zurückschwenken, weil das ist der angenehme Teil für mich, warum ich eigentlich, und da habe ich auch jetzt zwei Vorträge zugehalten. Das war kommerzielle Verwendung von OpenBSD. Dazu habe ich zwei Vorträge gehalten und habe in meinem Vortrag so ein bisschen erzählt, warum ich bei uns in der Firma gerne Kunden eine BSD-Lösung verkaufe und warum es für mich einfach ist, weil ich im Prinzip diese Lösung nehmen kann. Ich kann sie verändern, wie ich will und eventuell auch, und manche sehen es arschig an, manche nicht, ich kann sie erst mal zwei Stunden halbes oder ein Jahr bei uns verschlossen halten, um sie dann später vielleicht nochmal zu veröffentlichen. Aber ich kann mir, und das ist halt so ein bisschen das, wo die kommerzielle Welt ja auch anfängt, mir durchaus erst mal einen Marktvorteil verschaffen. Und was natürlich, und wir sind nun mal in so einer Commerzwelt an manchen Stellen, gerade wenn man auf diesem Technologiesektor arbeitet, wo man manchmal auch einen Vorsprung sich herausarbeiten muss. Und da hilft mir natürlich die BSD-Lizenz.
Und du findest, das widerspricht nicht dem Open-Source-Gedanken an der Stelle?
Nicht wirklich, weil zum Beispiel bei uns in der Firma arbeiten Leute, die der Open-Source-Community sehr nah sind, also unter anderem auch Open-BSD-Entwickler. Und damit ist ja so, wir tragen da zur Open-Source-Community bei, wo wir können, geben auch möglichst viel frei. Und das eine schließt das andere nicht aus. Nur weil ich zum Beispiel sage, okay, jetzt können wir ein Jahr lang das erstmal noch geschlossen halten. Anstatt es sofort freizugeben oder freigeben zu müssen, müssen wir sonst nicht nach den Regeln spielen. Wir spielen mit den Regeln. Und genau das ist ja auch das, was Theo zum Beispiel, wenn er sagt, er möchte ein BSD-basiertes Betriebssystem machen, was er den Leuten ermöglichen möchte. Wir BSD-Entwickler wollen ja den Leuten ermöglichen, dass sie aus unserer Sicht die größtmögliche Freiheit haben, mit dem zu machen, was sie möchten. Das ist ja genau das, wo sich diese Freiheit und Freiheit so ein bisschen, wo es ja doppeldeutig ist. Die einen meinen, Freiheit ist, wenn es immer wieder auch frei verfügbar ist, die anderen sagen, okay, eigentlich ist es komplett frei so, du kannst machen, was du willst damit.
Und das eine ist so ein bisschen die Freiheit des Individuums, das andere ist so ein bisschen die Freiheit von allen.
Ja, und das ist natürlich, also ich meine, ich denke mal, man muss das für sich selber, und das, denke ich mal, habe ich auch für mich gefunden, so einen Weg finden. Wir geben zum Beispiel bei uns halt möglichst viel frei und machen möglichst viel auch als Open Source bewusst. Aber manchmal ist es auch ganz praktisch, wenn man halt, oder wenn wir zum Beispiel an einer Kundenlösung arbeiten, mit einem Kunden zusammen, und der Kunde möchte es für sich als Produkt haben, machen wir ja auch, dann ist es praktisch für uns da halt einfach, an der Stelle so beistören zu können.
Vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen zurück auf diese Struktur, die du ja auch schon angesprochen hast. Also es gibt diesen schönen Begriff der Theokratie.
Der kommt von wem? Was heißt bei euch?
Okay, ich habe das mal gehört.
Was steckt dahinter? Also auf Englisch heißt das Theocracy. Das heißt eigentlich im Prinzip, was ich vorhin schon mal meinte, Theo ist der Chef, Theo ist oben und gibt erstmal an, was passiert. Du kannst entweder mitspielen, dann spielst du aber auch nach seinen Regeln mit oder du spielst nicht mit. Das ist ja jedermanns freie Entscheidung. Irgendwie weißt du, er macht bei dem Projekt mit, dann muss er aber auch Theos Regeln akzeptieren. Und dazu gehört halt einmal, dass wir bei OpenBSD relativ streng und viel mit Peer Review arbeiten. Das ist so eine der Sachen. Und wenn du damit nicht mitspielen kannst, wenn du also ständig im Source-Tree rumwerkelst, ohne deine Änderung vorher deinen Mitentwicklern zu zeigen, dann fliegst du halt raus. Das passiert auch. Also das ist halt nichts, was angedroht wird und nicht passiert, sondern das passiert. Dann ist halt dein Account einfach auch dicht.
Wie viele Leute arbeiten denn an OpenBSD auf dieser Ebene dann mit?
Auf der Ebene der Leute, die einfach committen können.
Welche Hierarchien gibt es denn?
Natürlich gibt es schon eine detaillierte Hierarchie, weil es einfach Leute gibt, die seit 10 Jahren OpenBSD-Committer sind. Und die haben natürlich eine gewisse Relevanz im Projekt. Aber ich würde es nicht unbedingt so sagen, dass die in Form von einer echten Hierarchie dir sagen, wo es lang geht, sondern du weißt einfach, du kannst dich an die Leute wenden, wenn du zum Beispiel auch Hilfe brauchst. Weil es gibt einfach Leute, die kennen sich in jedem Teil von OpenBSD aus. Und wenn ich an einem Teil arbeite, wo ich keine Ahnung davon habe, dann ist es für mich ganz selbstverständlich, dass ich auch mal den Leuten zeige, die den Teil gut kennen. Oder ich fahre da nach Hilfe. Und natürlich haben halt die Leute, die schon lange dabei sind, schon eine renommierte Stellung. Auf der anderen Seite ist es so, wenn die nicht nach der Regel spielen, fliegen die genauso raus. Und das ist, denke ich, mal auch...
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute bleiben denn da übrig?
Also ich glaube, es sind immer so zwischen 60 und 100 so.
Zwischen 60 und 100 Leuten, die sozusagen am Kern von oben BSD mitarbeiten?
Die halt ins Repository committen können.
Und du bist einer davon?
Einer, der im Augenblick auch leider nicht ganz so aktiv ist. Ich bin immer so, ich mache halt mal was und dann verschwinde ich wieder für eine Zeit.
Aber du hast noch nicht so weit gegen die Regeln verstoßen, dass du...
Ich habe das bisher tatsächlich vermeiden können, ja. Die anderen würden sagen, ich mache einfach nicht genug, damit ich gegen die Regeln verstoßen kann, aber das ist...
Man hat so den Eindruck von außen, man klang jetzt schon so ein bisschen an, so dieses Gemeinschaftsgefühl so ausgehend jetzt von diesen Postern und man merkt, dass irgendwie so ein Release wird gefeiert. OpenBSD-Community ist ja, habe ich schon erwähnt, bei CCC-Veranstaltungen seit langer Zeit sehr präsent. Ich weiß gar nicht, wann das angefangen hat. Also der schon erwähnte Wim ist natürlich immer vor Ort, aber es gibt dann immer eine größere Community auf dem Camp.
Das BSD-Village halt immer.
Wart ihr immer dabei, genau, und wollte ich gerade ansprechen. Also bis hin zu so einem eigenen Village des OpenBSD. Heißt es BSD-Village oder OpenBSD-Village eigentlich?
Das kommt so ein bisschen drauf an. Also ich würde es immer politisch korrekt BSD-Village nennen, aber wahrscheinlich ist es ein OpenBSD-Village. Wir sind halt schon, glaube ich, von denen, die im BSD-Village teilnehmen, von den Leuten, die da aufstehen, sind wir prozentual natürlich die meisten. Aber es liegt halt einfach daran, dass Leute wie Wim auch Leute ziehen und es einfach Spaß macht. Und ich glaube, aber letztendlich ist es ein BSD-Village, das hat jeder immer willkommen. Zum Beispiel bei What the Heck 2005, da waren einige Leute, die mittlerweile, da war zum Beispiel Sip, der ist ein Isländer, der war damals noch sehr im FreeBSD-Lage aktiv, aber auch nicht als Entwickler, sondern einfach so als User und Interessent. Und der war da bei uns, also im BSD-Village, hat da mit uns OpenBSD in Kontakt gehabt. Mittlerweile ist er wirklich ein aktiver OpenBSD-Entwickler und hat auch unter anderem am MFS viel geschraubt. Man könnte auch assimiliert sein, genau.
Man könnte ja auch, das ist das belgische Bier, was da eine größere Rolle spielt.
Richtig, es ist auf jeden Fall Bestandteil. Also Bier generell, aber...
Belgisches Bier da nochmal im Besonderen. Richtig.
Und Bikini-Contests, aber das wissen ja die Leute, die auf das...
Bikini-Contest, oh, davon habe ich nur gehört. Den gab es...
Du wirst ja wohl...
Gibt es das schon länger?
Also es gab auf What the Heck, glaube ich. Es gab es auf What the Heck eigentlich, meine ich. Und auf dem letzten CCC kam auf jeden Fall auch. Aber da du ja auf jeden Fall bei H vorbei kommen wirst, können wir dich da an Bikini stecken.
Na da, da reden wir aber nochmal drüber. Ja, kommen wir doch vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr auf die konkrete Technik bei OpenBSD zu sprechen. Also wir haben es ja schon erläutert. Es gibt halt diese verschiedenen BSDs. Und auf den ersten Blick sind die natürlich erst mal ähnlich. Weil es gibt halt diese gleiche Lizenzkultur, eben genau das mit der Freiheit, was wir schon angesprochen haben. Das ist ja bei FreeBSD und auch bei NetBSD nicht anders. Man fragt sich natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen, was außerhalb dieser Community und des Zusammenhaltes macht denn diese Projekte so unterschiedlich, sodass die auch lieber für sich alleine werkeln als so. Also was macht technisch OpenBSD aus? Was gehört überhaupt dazu?
Also zum einen denke ich mal, wenn ich an die Technik seitdenke, ist es natürlich so, und das haben wir unseren aktiven Wireless-Entwicklern zu verdanken, dass wir die Liste der BSD natürlich anführen, was den Wireless-Support, also von Wireless-Chips angeht, auf jeden Fall bei weitem anführen. Das ist natürlich so eine der Sachen, wo wir sehr gut sind. Also Raiq, der ja auch beim CCC durchaus bekannt ist, hat ja unter anderem auch da viel mitgemacht. Und wenn man sich zum Beispiel Open Solaris anguckt, da sind mittlerweile viele Treiber für Wireless-Interfaces auf Open Solaris kommen von OpenBSD. Und das zeigt natürlich schon, dass wir da auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen der Marktschüre auch sind, wenn man mal so das Wort benutzt.
Das ist ja nochmal so eine ganz eigene Geschichte, nicht wahr? Vielleicht müssen wir das Problem ja auch nochmal kurz skizzieren. Treiber für Wireless-Karten, also Devices, wie auch immer, die man an den Rechner anschließt, sind meistens geschlossene Treiber.
Ja, man muss ein bisschen unterscheiden. Es gibt halt die Karten, zum Beispiel war die Arthros-Karte früher so eine. Mittlerweile ist das Teil, glaube ich, auch geopensourced worden von Sam Loeffler, aber früher war es so. Es gibt häufig Karten, die haben im Prinzip veröffentlichen, also zum Beispiel bei den Intel-Karten, da gibt es auch Specs oder Treiber für von Intel, aber sie haben halt immer noch so ein Firmware-Interface. Und diese Firmware ist letztendlich da, wo eine Menge Logik mit drin ist, und das gibt es halt nur binär. Und das ist so eine der Sachen, wo OpenBSD tatsächlich dann, eben weil wir halt die ganzen Treiber darauf versucht haben, politisch zu agieren und auch auf die Hersteller zuzugehen und zu sagen, Leute, dass es Cup ist. Dass es sie binär gibt an sich, ist zwar unschön, aber viel schlimmer ist, dass es sie meistens auch noch mit einer Lizenz gibt, dass man sie nicht weiter verteilen darf. Das heißt, wir müssen eigentlich einen Release ausliefern, der zwar den Wireless-Support an sich für die Karte hat, aber die Karte funktioniert nicht, weil man erst auf die Webseite von irgendwo gehen muss, um sich diese Firma zu laden, um sie dann zum Laufen zu kriegen. Und da gab es halt zu, und ich bin ein bisschen, ich glaube, es war 3.9, da gab es die Stop-Blob-Kampagne auch von OpenBSD, da gibt es das passende T-Shirt zu.
Stop-Blob, Blob steht für?
Blob an sich steht für Binary Large Object. Und stand halt da im Prinzip für jegliche Art von proprietären und lizenzverknäuselten Dingern, die man zusätzlich laden muss, um die Karte ans Laufen zu kriegen. Und da gab es eigentlich auch, glaube ich, Theo, ich meine in dem Rahmen, auf der Fostum damals auch einen Award bekommen, Free Software war das, das war eine der Sachen, wo...
Von Richard Stolmen persönlich.
Genau, wo sich die beiden auch mal wieder begegnet sind.
Was sie sonst nicht so häufig tun.
Richtig, aber wo tatsächlich, wo ja im Prinzip auch, womit sich so ein bisschen der Kreis um eher zu dieser Freiheit schließt, wo tatsächlich OpenBSD politisch auch sehr vorgeprescht ist. Und wo es gibt ja zum Beispiel bei FreeBSD, meine ich, gab es halt auch diesen Endless-Rapper, der halt irgendwelche Windows-Dinger nimmt und die dann noch laden kann, damit man diese Devices trotzdem benutzen kann. Und OpenBSD hat halt von sich aus gesagt, so etwas importieren wir gar nicht erst bei uns in das Frosttree, weil das ist eigentlich Schummeln. Und eigentlich wollen wir das nicht und wir boykottieren es. Und wo wir uns natürlich auch so ein bisschen dann überkreuzern mit anderen Leuten, wo dann Theo aber, finde ich, sehr gut gesagt hat, einfach unsere Linie auch behalten, da hat OpenBSD einfach seine Linie behalten. Und das fand ich sehr gut.
Und wie ist es dann zu diesen ganzen Treibern gekommen? Ist das dann im Wesentlichen so Re-Engineering gewesen, dass sich Leute hingesetzt haben und es einfach...
Also wir haben einen verrückten Entwickler, das ist Damien Berger-Mimi. Und der rotzt irgendwie alle paar Monate spätestens einen neuen Treiber raus. Also der ist eine Treibermaschine. Der schreibt für die ganzen neuen Intel-Chips, die in so Sachen wie X200, X300, X60, die ganzen IBM-Notebooks, sind ja alles irgendwie Intel-Chips drin. Intel Pro Wireless und all sowas. Und Damien rotzt einen Treiber nach dem anderen raus. Ich weiß nicht, wie das macht, aber er macht es. Du siehst halt, da kommt irgendwie so ein Wumpern im Meer, so ja, hier ist ein Treiber dafür, hier ist ein Treiber dafür. Es ist faszinierend.
Aber er hat jetzt keine Dokumentation oder so?
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich könnte noch mal bei Damien nachfragen. Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich glaube, der... Ob Intel da Specks rausgibt? Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, die sind alle irgendwie...
Zumindest hilft ihm jetzt so keiner konkret mit der Code-Entwicklung.
Und ich glaube, der hat auch die Treiber für... Und da bin ich ein bisschen schwach. Ich glaube, der hat auch die Treiber für die Raling device geschrieben. Und Raling ist, glaube ich, eine von den Firmen, die sehr ordentlich mit Specks umgegangen sind. Die wirklich die Specks zur Verfügung stellen. Und es ist ja auch so, dass nicht jeder Hardware-Hersteller wirklich per se böse ist. Also es gibt diverse Beispiele, wo unsere Entwickler... Also zum Beispiel beim... Ich glaube, es war beim 10er Gigabit-Treiber-Bereich, wo sie wirklich von den Herstellern auch sehr gute Dokumentationen bekommen haben und sehr viel Hilfe und dann Testkarten, also Teststellung von Karten und all sowas. Da, meine ich, hat DLG aus Australien auch irgendwie einen Treiber geschrieben, der halt genau da aufbasiert, oft wirklich in einer guten Kooperation mit einem Hersteller.
Das heißt, es gibt Hersteller, die das eigentlich auch durchaus verstehen, die Argumente?
Es gibt Hersteller, die einfach gerne ihre Produkte auch von freiem Betriebssystem unterstützt haben wollen. Es gibt... ganz spannend, also einer der Bereiche, wo wir sowieso ganz weit vorne sind, wir haben ja einen unglaublichen Support für Funk-Uren.
Für Funk-Uren?
Ja, richtig. Und zwar kann man ja im Prinzip, also wenn man einen Zeitserver aufsetzt, kann man entweder einen NTP-D nehmen, den mit anderen NTP-Servern zynken, oder man hat selbst halt eine Uhrquelle, die sich halt mit so einem echten Zeitsignal synchronisiert.
So ein DCF-77-Empfänger, schön aus Braunschweig, immer schön den Takt.
Richtig, genau. Und einer, also absurderweise sogar ein Schweizer, Marc Bäumer, der eigentlich auch immer auf den CCC-Events dabei ist, der hat jede Menge Support für diese Devices geschrieben. Also sei es USB-Attached, DCF-77 heißt das, glaube ich, oder PCI oder was auch immer. Und da gibt es zwei Herstellen. Einer ist, wie heißt denn der?
Ist denn das kompensiert, so eine Uhr auszulesen? Verstehe ich da gerade was nicht?
Keine Ahnung, ich supporte die auf jeden Fall. Gerade bei PCI-Devices muss man schon noch ein bisschen was machen, damit man mit denen schnacken kann. Das USB ist glaube ich immer ein bisschen einfacher, aber PCI ist schon was anderes. Und ich glaube, Meinberg ist der eine große Hersteller und die machen es mittlerweile sogar so, dass sie ihn anrufen. Ja, hey, Mr. Boimer, wir haben hier ein neues Gerät. Wir würden Ihnen das jetzt mal zuschicken, damit Sie einen Treiber dafür schreiben können. Und so etwas verdient eigentlich Applaus, weil ich denke, da hat es den Hersteller immer wirklich begriffen. Und das ist einfach eine super Kooperation. Marc Boimer schreibt jetzt die Treiber dafür, kriegt von denen immer die Dokumentation und dann auch immer so, ja, und wenn Sie Fragen haben, hier haben Sie die Telefonnummer von dem Hardware-Entwickler bei uns, rufen Sie einfach an, können Sie einen fragen. Also man schimpft ja immer sehr gerne auf die Industrie und auf die Hersteller, aber ich denke mal, es gibt ja genau die andere Seite auch, wo im Prinzip freie Software-Entwickler oder freie Betriebssystem-Entwickler und die Industrie auch sehr gut zusammenarbeiten können, indem sie halt so kooperieren.
Ja, der positive Einfluss vom OpenBSD-Projekt, was gerade wireless Treiber betrifft, kam ja auch schon mal zur Sprache. Ich habe mal mit dem Felix Fietkow Chaosradio Express gemacht zum Projekt OpenWRT, wo wir auch sehr viel über diesen Aspekt gesprochen haben. Jetzt haben wir sozusagen mal auch die andere Seite gehört. Das bringt mich jetzt auch auf den Punkt, viele fragen sich natürlich bei so einem Betriebssystem immer, ich meine, kein Betriebssystem ist für alles. Das ist bisher noch nicht erfunden worden, auch wenn man sagen kann, Unix als solches in all seinen Ausprägungen, ob jetzt so in der traditionellen Unix-Form, wie bei BSD, oder eben in der Linux-Form. Keins deckt irgendwie wirklich so richtig alles ab. Nur Linux versucht sozusagen überall ein bisschen mitzuspielen, deckt das dann wiederum eher, sagen wir mal, über die Distributionsseite ab. OpenBSD, habe ich so den Eindruck, ist sowohl im Serverbereich als auch im Embedded-Bereich sehr stark, während jetzt so Laptops oder so, die nicht so die Stärke sind, oder? Also, vielleicht kannst du mal was dazu sagen, wo macht OpenBSD Sinn und wo greift man da vielleicht zu was anderem?
Das ist schon eine schwierige Frage. Ja, deswegen wäre auch bei Chaosradio Express der Punkt, ganz für schwierige Fragen. Es gibt zum Beispiel von FreeBeasty, also ich habe von einem FreeBeasty-Entwickler vor einer Zeit ein Statement auf einer Mail-Liste gelesen, wo er sagte, naja, mal ganz ehrlich, ich setze FreeBeasty seit Jahren nur noch auf dem Server ein, auf dem Desktop, als Desktop habe ich einen Mac. Das fand ich schon ein bisschen schade, weil man kann es natürlich nur auf dem Server und auf dem Mac als Desktop haben, aber auf der anderen Seite macht es, glaube ich, auch schon für mich Spaß, OpenBSD auf dem Desktop zu haben. Wir haben Leute, die kümmern sich sehr aktiv um die Desktop-Komponenten. Es ist natürlich etwas anderes als ein Mac zum Beispiel, als Desktop, aber wenn ich ein OpenBSD zum Beispiel als Desktop einsetzen würde, dann will ich das genau. Deswegen muss ich schon sagen, dass das passt irgendwie. Für mich als Desktop ist es okay, weil ich genug drin stecke. Meine Oma würde ich es nicht vorsetzen. Und da ist es natürlich für mich schon so, dass es perfekt in den Serverbereich reinpasst. Wobei ich zum Beispiel auch immer wieder feststelle, in dem Moment, wo wir zum Beispiel über einen Web-Server reden, der relativ performant sein soll, oder einen Datenbank-Server, da würde ich es nicht einsetzen. Warum? Also zum Beispiel haben wir auf I386, also wenn man nicht AMD 64 nimmt, sondern eine 32-bitige Plattform haben wir. Das Problem ist, dass wir nur 3,5 Giga weit Speicher adressieren können, weil wir kein PIE haben, kein Fulke Address Extension.
Und in 64 Bit gibt es OpenBSD auch noch nicht?
AMD 64 wäre es doch, 64 Bit, da kann man natürlich dann mehr Speicher adressieren. Unter AMD 64 laufen wiederum gewisse andere Sachen nicht. Dann ist natürlich der Punkt, dass wir so rein vom Betriebssystemaufbau her, war OpenBSD noch nie darauf ausgelegt, möglichst höchst performant zu sein. Das war einfach nicht der Fokus.
Was war denn der Fokus?
Sicherheit, Stabilität, ein sauberes Betriebssystem herzustellen. Zum Beispiel haben wir, wenn wir zum Beispiel über SMP, über Multiprozessoren reden, wir haben halt noch einen Giant-Log. FreeBSD hat keinen Giant-Log. FreeBSD hat den sogenannten Fine-Grained-Log. Das heißt, du hast einen Kern...
Giant-Log? Das musst du mal erklären.
Du hast ja, wenn du dir eine Unix-Körne anguckst und die Multiprozessor-Maschine anguckst, es ist so, dass... Ich bin nun absolut kein Experte auf dem Bereich, aber ich würde es mal summa summarum so salopp zusammenfassen, dass du sagst, bei OpenBSD, wenn du den Körner betrittst, ist der Körner zu und kein anderer kann rein. Dann gehst du wieder raus in deinem Prozess-Kontext, dann bist du wieder raus und dann kann der nächste. Und FreeBSD hat halt genau seit 2, 3 Jahren lang oder länger dran gesessen, das große Locking wegzuhauen und überall kleine Locks zu bauen. Okay, verstehe.
Die Rehentrans.
Ich bin halt wirklich nicht gut auf dem Mieter, aber ich kann es halt so, glaube ich, salopp erklären. Und das merkt man schon. Das merkt man auch wirklich massiv, denke ich mal. Wir haben nicht umsonst, jetzt setzen wir zum Beispiel auch an verschiedenen Stellen, eben nicht OpenBSD, wenn es darum geht, möglichst schnell zu sein. Firewalls, ganz klar, da müssen wir nicht drüber reden. Das ist eindeutig ein absolutes Ding für OpenBSD. Redonanzverbände zwischen Firewalls zu bauen, absolut simpel, IPSEC, IPSEC-Konfiguration unter OpenBSD ist trivial. Wir haben seit einiger Zeit, ich glaube seit 3,8 oder so, die sogenannte ipsec.conf für die Leute, die die pf.conf kennen, die ist vom Aufbau her genau ähnlich und man kann im Prinzip zwei Maschinen mit IPSEC mit drei Zeilen auf jeder Seite pro Konfig-Datei zusammen verknüpfen. Du kannst IPSEC innerhalb von 5 Minuten bauen. Das zeigt man auf einem anderen Betriebssthema. Sonst war IPSEC immer so eine hohe Kunst und Magie. Da haben sie es geschafft, das sehr simpel hinzukriegen. Also im Bereich Fireballs, VPN, das ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema, wo ich nichts anderes dranlasse. Wo auch bei uns immer nur OpenBSD eingesetzt werden würde. Side-Server, jegliche Art von Basis-Internet-Infrastruktur kann man mit OpenBSD sehr gut abbilden. Wir haben diverse Routing-Demons im Basis-System, die auch neu geschrieben wurden. Die alten, doch recht löchrigen Sachen wurden durch Neu ersetzt. Gerade Henning Brauer hat ja OpenPGPD geschrieben, also einen kompletten PGP-Demon.
Klingt so ein bisschen wie PGP.
Nein, das meinen wir jetzt nicht.
Border-Gateway-Protokoll, das Protokoll, das im Internet zwischen den autonomen Systemen gesprochen wird, um das Routing zu organisieren.
Richtig.
Das war ein wohlbeachtetes Projekt, hatte ich so den ein.
Das ist ja auch eine Nische gewesen.
Es gab eigentlich nur kommerzielle Implementierungen.
Es gibt noch die Zebra, was recht gammelig sein soll. Das weiß ich aber auch nur aus dem Vortrag von Henning, weil ich mich mit dem Routing von AS noch nicht beschäftigt habe. Ich habe selber auch das nicht im Einsatz. Das ist eine der Sachen, wo du mit dem Basis-System eine Menge an Kern-Funktialität abdenken kannst. Wir haben mittlerweile Failover der CPD im Basis-System, was auch ganz nett ist. Was ist das? Dass du mehrere DHCP-Server im Failover-Modus fahren kannst, was auch ganz praktisch ist.
Also zwischen verschiedenen Systemen, wenn der eine nicht mehr surft, dann macht der andere was. Das sind alles Sachen, die man sich nicht bauen muss. Das sind Kern-Funktionalitäten, die dann auch fest in den Release mit reingehemmert sind.
Ja, die werden Stück für Stück eingebaut. Wir haben eine sehr schöne Spam-Abwehr eingebaut, Bob Beck, einer der kanadischen Leute, der in Zusammenhang mit unserem perfekt funktionierenden Packetfilter zusammenarbeitet. Das ist der beste Packetfilter, den es auf dem Markt gibt.
Da können wir ruhig noch ein bisschen reingehen. Du hast es jetzt schon mehrfach betont, dass Firewall eine Domäne von OpenBSD sei. Meine Firewalls haben sie ja irgendwie alle.
Richtig, aber dadurch, dass wir, es gab ja auch da wieder mal so, war Lizenz der Ausgang. Es gab früher in OpenBSD wie in den anderen BSDs den IPF. Das war der IP-Filter. Genau, und der wird von Darren Reed entwickelt. Der hat seine Lizenz damals geändert. Auf was? Er hat damals eine Klausel hinzugeschrieben, sodass wir IPF problemlos distributieren dürfen und auch ein Barsystem haben dürfen, wie alle anderen BSDs, die ihn ja auch haben.
Es war auf jeden Fall nicht mehr so frei, wie man das eigentlich gewohnt ist bei einer BSD-Lizenz.
Vor allem, wie Theos Anspruch ist. Dann haben wir überlegt und IPF rausgeschmissen. Da hatten wir zuerst gar keinen Paketfilter mehr. Es gab eine Kurzzeit, wo wir kein Paketfilter am Barsystem hatten. Dann hat Daniel Hartmeier aus der Schweiz angefangen, PF zu entwickeln. Er war damals noch kein OpenBSD-Entwickler. Er hat den einfach angefangen zu entwickeln. Der hat den anderen so gut gefallen, dass sie ihn sofort importiert haben. Dann wurde innerhalb von zwei, drei Monaten ein Basispaketfilter geschrieben.
Er ist extrem simpel zu konfigurieren.
Du kannst das Konfig-File einfach so herunterlesen, was natürlich für das Fehler-Suchen bzw. Verstehen von bestehenden Regeln das Ganze sehr einfach macht. Anders als, finde ich zum Beispiel, IP-Tables. IP-Tables ist durchaus wesentlich komplizierter zu verstehen.
Was bei Linux vor allem im Einsatz ist.
Richtig. Seitdem wurde er um viele Funktionen erweitert. PF-Sync, dass du tatsächlich zwei Firewalls haben kannst, die im Prinzip erst mal im Redonanzverband sind, über Carb. Und über PF-Sync können dir auch die Firewall-States tatsächlich austauschen, sodass tatsächlich eine komplett den anderen ersetzen kann. Inklusive aller TCP-States und allem.
Verstehe. Also dieses Konzept, so Failover-Systeme zu haben und dabei auch alle möglichen Settings auszutauschen, das scheint hier so ein wiederkehrendes Ding zu sein.
IP-SEC. Geht auch mit IP-SEC. Also wir haben den SaSync-D, das ist ein Demon, der sich um die Synchronisation von IP-SEC-States kümmert. So dass wenn du deine zwei Firewalls hast, also du hast deine zwei Firewalls an Standort A, dann Standort B und die machen auch noch IP-SEC miteinander, weil die Standorte vernetzt sind, dann hast du tatsächlich sogar auf jedem Redonanten-System die IP-SEC-States, was hervorragend ist. Ich meine, das heißt, du kannst eine Maschine einfach komplett abrauchen und die Leute merken es nicht mal.
Das heißt, die andere Maschine übernimmt dann die...
Alles.
Den Tunnel, was auch immer den Zugang, den sicheren Zugang zwischen den beiden...
Und das natürlich mit... Wenn du letztendlich sagst, kannst du auf jeder Hardware irgendwie installieren und bezahlst für das CD-Set 50 Euro, kommen das dann eigentlich nur Features, die man sonst von Cisco kennt. Und da muss man wesentlich mehr bezahlen. Ich finde es schon geil, dass so etwas als freies Software so verfügbar ist.
Also OpenBSD ist vor allem so ein bisschen der Sicherheits-Baukasten. Kann man das so sagen? Also ich sage nicht nur ausschließlich so, aber das ist definitiv eine Komponente. Sicherheit im Sinne von Zugang. OpenSSH haben wir ja schon erwähnt. Kann man auch nochmal erwähnen. Ist ein Projekt, das bei OpenBSD gestartet wurde. Ich glaube, das war so. Damit fing irgendwie ein bisschen alles an, oder? Bring ich da was durcheinander?
Nee, es fing nicht alles damit an, aber es war auf jeden Fall der Punkt, wo wir richtig populär wurden.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall schon so ein spezielles, ein Aushängeschild des Projekts.
Es fing nicht damit an, weil ich meine, OpenSSH kommt von 1997. Und OpenBSD hat ja 1995 angefangen, und ich meine OpenSSH 97.
Ja gut, ich wollte jetzt nicht so auf die Sekunde timen, aber es war halt so, man hat halt gemerkt, dass OpenBSD-Projekt existiert, und dann kam irgendwann OpenSSH raus, und das ist ja heutzutage einfach auf allen, also es gibt keine andere SSH, oder?
Ja, wenn man auf die OpenSSH-Seite geht, haben wir ja Links zu anderen Implementierungen. Es gibt halt zum Beispiel eine SSH-Implementierung in Java. Es gibt andere Implementierungen, zum Beispiel auch von der Firma SSH. Ich glaube, die heißt mittlerweile Secure Communications oder so was. Die geben auch eine kommerzielle Secure Shell raus noch. Das ist ja von dem, SSH war ja usch. Es gab SSH an sich ja keine komplette Entwicklung oder OpenSSH von scratch. Es gab eine SSH, die war unter einer freien Lizenz. Und die wurde dann ja verändert. Und dann haben Theo und zwei, drei andere das geforkt von da an. Und das war dann die Basis für OpenSSH.
Und was ist an OpenSSH jetzt so toll gewesen, dass es die anderen SSHs so ausmanövriert hat in der Popularität?
Also wir haben im Prinzip jede Menge, es ist ja erstmal auch ein Standard. Und in dem Standard haben sie halt alles so entwickelt, was möglich ist. Und ich meine, es war auch die, die als erstes komplett irgendwie das Zweierprotokoll und sowas komplett erfüllt hat. Aber da müsste ich auch selber in der Mainpage nachlesen.
Aber wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, wurde ja auch immer so ein bisschen mit der Fehlerfreiheit und der eigentlichen Sicherheit geprahlt. Gab es da nicht sogar mal so eine Wette oder so, einen findet den Fehler? Bounty-Hunting? Das weiß ich nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht. Aber es gibt ja nach wie vor diesen Spruch, den wir auf der Webseite haben, so und so viele Jahre ohne Remote Root Hole. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie viel es mittlerweile gibt. Ja, in der Default-Installation. Das muss man leider so ein bisschen auch enthämisch grinsen. Es ist ja immer so eine Auslegungssache. Es gab diverse Leute, die sagen, der Spruch ist nicht mehr gültig, weil ich habe das und das gefunden. Und dann wurde immer gesagt, ja, aber das ist in der Default-Installation nicht an. Tut mir leid. Also von daher ist es natürlich das, was...
Ach so, ein Dienst, der nicht eingeschaltet ist. Aber wenn man ihn einschaltet, dann hat man so einen Remote-Roll.
Richtig. Also eigentlich dürfte ich das jetzt... So nicht, ne? Aber eigentlich ist es so eine Spitzfindigkeit, finde ich persönlich. Also, dass man sagt, so in der Default-Installation. Aber letztendlich kann es ja schon, ne? Wenn du dir anguckst, der Security-Record ist exzellent. Muss man einfach sagen.
Und es gibt durchaus Systeme, die in der Default-Installation mit solchen Remote-Rolls daherkommen.
Diverse, oder nicht? Wir haben vorhin ein Thema geschrieben, wo ich noch einmal kurz zurückkommen würde. Du hattest mich gefragt, wo man z.B. OpenBSD einsetzen und wo man es nicht einsetzen würde. Und ein Thema, also einer der Punkte, merke ich auch, weil ich mich gerade ein bisschen mit dem Thema auch so beschäftige bei uns in der Firma, ist z.B. Dateiserver. Weil das ist halt eine der Sachen, wo wir natürlich noch extrem Probleme haben. Also so große Dateisysteme mit OpenBSD zu realisieren, also auch gerade so große NFS-Zwerber, wir reden jenseits von Terabyte. Das ist so ein Punkt, wo ich z.B. OpenBSD gar nicht sehe im Augenblick. Wir unterstützen das nicht sinnvoll. Wir haben zwar UFS2, aber es ist, wer schon mal irgendwie einen FSDK von 500 GB unter OpenBSD gesehen hat, das geht einfach ein, weil es ewig dauert.
Wird denn ZFS diskutiert in der OpenBSD-Gemeinde?
Nein, weil ZFS hat die falsche Lizenz. Hat es? ZFS hat keine freie Lizenz. Viel spannender ist aber, und deswegen reden wir wieder ein bisschen über Relevanz, von Dragonfly-BSD. Dragonfly, Matt Dillon, arbeitet seit einiger Zeit an Hammer, was ein Dateisystem ist, was ähnlich zukunftsrechtlich ist wie ZFS. Hammer hätte zum Beispiel die richtige Lizenz.
Was ist denn an der CDDL, die Community von ZAD? Was ist an der falsch?
Ich bin kein Lizenzexpert. Sie passen nicht richtig. Es hat noch niemand diskutiert, Hammer zu portieren. Es würde von der Lizenz passen, weil es BSD-lizenziert ist. Das Problem ist, dass diese Subsysteme zu sehr divergieren, sodass man sie sich nehmen und schnell portieren kann. Wenn man in die Richtung denkt, wäre das Hammer von Dragonfly BSD schon schön. Vielleicht nutzt sich auch einer der Hörer vom Chaosradio dafür. So etwas zu portieren.
ZDFs ist ja gerade so ein bisschen das...
Das ist das, was wir im Augenblick überlegen wollen.
Das heiße Kind, das die machen, hat auf jeden Fall interessante Vorlage gemacht. Aber hier soll es nicht über ZDFs gehen. ZDFs war hier aber auch schon mal Thema. Also wer zu ZDFs was hören will, gab es bei Chaosradio Express auch schon eine tolle Sendung. Vielleicht sollte ich auch mal die... Die Episoden-Nummer noch mal kurz erwähnen. Also ZDFs war Chaosradio Express 49 und die Open-WRT-Sendung war 76. Die hatte ich ja auch schon erwähnt. Ja, waren wir jetzt bei dem Open-SSH schon durch? Ja, da waren wir schon vorbei. Ich würde gerne noch mal so ein bisschen verstehen. Also dieses... Ich sage jetzt mal positiv, dieser Sicherheitsfanatismus. Ja, so dieses es muss sicher sein. Also es gab ja da auch verschiedene Sachen. Ich mich richtig erinnere, wurde ja zum Beispiel dieses man kann nicht mehr in den Stack schreiben Feature, wurde glaube ich von Theodor Rath...
Writer Execute, ja, richtig...
.pioniert.
WoX, richtig.
Kannst du ja vielleicht mal kurz erläutern?
Ja, letztendlich, wenn du natürlich, wenn du einen Stack hast und du kannst einen Stack schreiben und den ausführen, ist das natürlich genau die Methode, wie du eigentlich einen Exploit auch reinkriegst. Du hast im Prinzip einen Buffer-Overflow, kannst von dort aus in den Stack reinschreiben, hast im Prinzip eine Speicherregion, wo du deinen Zeugs reinlegen kannst und dann kannst du es ausführen.
Und das ist eigentlich das, worauf die meisten Demotexploits basieren.
Richtig, und wenn du erst mal eine Speicherregion, wenn du sie entweder nur schreiben oder nur ausführen kannst, dann kannst du schon mal nicht mehr hinschreiben und sie ausführen. Also, sehr simpel gesagt, ist genau das. Und das ist natürlich, erst mal funktionieren damit die meisten Demotexploits nicht mehr.
Und gab es da noch so andere Sicherheitstechniken, die jetzt, sagen wir mal, von der Programmierung oder von dem, wie das Betriebssystem so mit ihren Programmen umgeht, die in OpenBSD eingeführt wurden, die so von anderen übernommen wurden?
Von anderen übernommen wurden, es gibt...
Oder vielleicht auch nicht übernommen wurden, die aber trotzdem da sind und interessant sind.
Also eine Sache, die ja Nils Probus irgendwann entwickelt hat, war ja das Systrace, was es auch auf anderen Plattformen gibt. Es gab sogar mal eine Portierung auf Darwin. Das Systrace ist im Prinzip aber das, dass du letztendlich einmal bei einem Programm die System-Calls tracen kannst und dann kannst du letztendlich ein Profil anlegen, welches System-Calls im Programm machen darf. Dann haben wir verschiedene Erweiterungen zum GCC, die im Prinzip dem GCC helfen, gewisse Sachen auch zu finden und zu vermeiden. Das war nicht so ganz meine Region. Eine der anderen Sachen, die ich meine, die gar nicht mal technisch sind, sondern eher philosophisch und von der Rangehensweise ist einfach, dass wir, glaube ich, eine ganz andere Art haben, mit dem System umzugehen, beim Entwickeln als andere Betriebssysteme. Du hast ja ein sicheres System, baust du erstmal, indem du auf Komplexität verzichtest. Komplexe Systeme sind automatisch, denke ich mal, fehleranfälliger und auch gegen Sicherheitslücken anfälliger als simple Systeme, weil jeder einfach mehr durchschauen kann. Ein simples System ist viel einfacher zu verstehen, auch für den Entwickler. Und das ist natürlich etwas schon, was sich bei OpenBSD auch von A bis Ende durchzieht, dass man versucht, Sachen simpel zu halten. Anstatt Layer um Layer um Layer zu abstrahieren, dass man einfach versucht, Sachen simpel zu lösen.
Auch wenn es unter Umständen im Bereich Performance einem dann auf die Füße fällt?
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Und es gibt genauso, es ist natürlich ein bisschen so, die alte Leier, aber letztendlich ist dokumentierter Code und dokumentierte Schnittstellen helfen auch wiederum. Ein sauberes System halten. Und wir haben bei OpenBSD prinzipiell auch diese Regel, dass fehlende Dokumentation oder falsche Dokumentation ein Bug ist.
Das heißt, es gibt für alles generell auf jeden Fall immer Dokumentation?
Die Manpages sind unter OpenBSD einzigartig. Ich kenne kein Unix-System, das so sauber und so eine gute Online-Hilfe hat. Du arbeitest an einem OpenBSD-System und du findest zu allem eine gute Manpage. Und wir haben einen Entwickler, JMC, der nur an Manpages arbeitet. Der kümmert sich nur darum, dass die wirklich …Wenn Entwickler Manpage schreiben, ist das eine Sache. Aber wenn du jemanden hast, der nativ enggespricht und dahinter auch aufräumt, dann sind die Manpages hinterher auch nicht nur komplett, sondern sind auch gut lesbar. Das ist auch noch mal so eine Sache, die man auch einfach hochschätzen muss. Und ohne JMC wäre jeder von den OpenBSD-Entwicklern, der schon mal Dokumentationen gemacht hat, völlig aufgeschmissen. Weil du machst irgendeine Änderung an der Manpage. Und du weißt auf jeden Fall, der JMC räumt sich noch mal eben auf, guckt und macht es schöner. Und das gibt einfach schon ein gutes Gefühl, wenn man das System wieder benutzt. Und wenn ich irgendwie auf OpenBSD arbeite, weiß ich, ich muss nur man-minus-k Schlagwort, dann sehe ich die Manpage, wo es drin steht und kann einfach da nachlesen. Und das ist super angenehm und eigentlich professionell, finde ich. Also für mich ist das genau das, was ich von einem Betriebssthema auch erwarte, dass es mir so zur Hand geht. Und so ist es nicht nur bei den User-Land-Kommandos und solchen Sondern, sondern so ist es dann auch bei den Programmierschnittstellen. Es gibt natürlich gewisse Programmierschnittstellen, die überhaupt bis gar nicht dokumentiert sind nach wie vor. Aber es wird halt zunehmend weniger. Und das ist schon etwas, was ich meine, was abseits der rein technischen Lösung für Sicherheit auch hilft und auch ein System sicherer macht. Und genauso ist ja die Qualität des Codes, den OpenBSD-Entwicklern, sehr wichtig. Und Qualität des Codes erzeugst du über das, was ich vorhin schon erwähnt hatte, diese Peer Review, dass tatsächlich andere Leute mit drauf gucken. Weil es ist klar, vier, sechs Augen sehen mehr als zwei.
Ich meine, OpenBSD ist ja nun auch ein Projekt, wo die Leute quer über den Planeten verteilt sind.
Richtig, also wir haben zum einen ICB, das ist ähnlich IRC. Das ist halt so ein Chat-Kanal, wo wir drauf sitzen.
ICB, ist das jetzt ein Server oder eine Software?
Das ist eine Software. Es steht für Internet Citizen Broadband, wie früher CB-Funk, aber halt für Internet. Sieht aus wie IRC. Kann man sich jeder vorstellen wie IRC, ist ein nicht öffentlicher Server, wo die Entwickler drauf sind. Und da kann man sich halt unterhalten.
Warum nimmt ihr dann nicht IRC?
Weil CEO schon immer ICB benutzt.
Punkt. Die Bibel ist da auch nicht anders.
Richtig, also Punkt. Wir benutzen ICB und Mailingliste natürlich. Und generell ist es halt so, wenn ich eine Änderung machen will, in einem bestimmten Bereich, dann schicke ich das entsprechend an verschiedene Entwickler und die geben mir ihr Okay. Und deswegen, wenn man zum Beispiel mal in unsere Mailingliste für die...
Was heißt, das interessiert mich jetzt. Nehmen wir doch mal ein Beispiel. Also was würdest du jetzt vielleicht in Angriff nehmen und woher weißt du, mit wem du dich dann koordinieren willst?
Also ich habe zum Beispiel an einem UMTS-Treiber was geändert. Also ich möchte was ändern, möchte irgendwie was hinzufügen als Funktion.
Also was Neues, kein Bug-Fix, sondern irgendwie es geht jetzt hier um steigende Komplexität und dann haben alle wahrscheinlich gleich so die Alarmglocken.
Du machst aber schon eine Unterscheidung. Auch vielleicht auf meine Sicht ein Bug-Fix kann andere Sachen wieder kaputt machen.
Das stimmt.
Und deswegen, entweder ich gucke mit CVS-Log an, wer hat als letztes in dem Bereich gearbeitet. Ich frage auf ICB, wer interessiert sich für den Bereich, wer kann mir dazu Feedback geben. Oder ich schreibe es einfach an die generelle Magenliste von uns intern.
OpenBSD noch mit CVS gemacht?
Ja, aber jetzt lass uns nicht vom Thema abpumpen, weil das ist nämlich ein wichtiger Punkt jetzt. Es ist einfach ein entscheidender Punkt bei OpenBSD. Dann schicke ich das raus an die Leute und die gucken sich die Änderung an, also den Diff, den ich ihnen rausgemeldet habe, und sagen mir dann halt, ob die Änderung okay ist oder nicht. Und wenn ich nicht ein paar Okays habe, darf ich es nicht comitten. Es gibt natürlich Änderungen, die so minimal sind, dass man sie eben so reinhaut. Aber eigentlich ist die Regel so, lieber ein Okay holen von irgendjemandem.
Also, obwohl du es einfach cometten könntest und du für dich auch weißt, das heißt ja nichts, was ich für mich weiß. Genau, das heißt nichts. Das heißt zumindest, dass du glaubst, dass es jetzt irgendwie okay ist. Und dann gehst du auf die Meldingsliste und sagst, ich würde gerne einchecken folgendes. Und dann wartest du darauf, bis wer das dann... Also, ich meine, gibt es dann eine bestimmte Person oder gibt es dann eine bestimmte Anzahl oder haben die alle so einen Entwicklerpunkt?
Nein, nein, nein. Normalerweise würde ich immer genau die anmelden, von denen ich weiß, die arbeiten in dem Bereich. Und wenn du normalerweise in so einem Betrieb mitarbeitest, weißt du, wer in welchem Bereich arbeitet. Weil du liest ja auch die Meldingsliste für die CVS-Commits. Das heißt, du weißt, wer in dem Bereich arbeitet. Oder du guckst eben mit dem Kommando CVS-Log, wer die Datei das letzte Mal angefasst hat.
Okay, aber es ist im Prinzip deine Sache, die richtigen Leute zu finden. Es ist nicht so, dass es irgendwo so eine Textdatei gibt, wo drauf steht, wenn du da was ändern willst, dann musst du den fragen.
Nein, wir haben eine interne Datei, wo drin steht, wer sich für welche Bereiche interessiert. Aber da trägt man sich mal ein, wenn man mit dem Projekt anfängt. Ich weiß nicht, ob jeder das für sich so.
Okay, aber es geht im Primär darum, dass man überhaupt andere gefragt hat.
Richtig, genau. Es geht darum, dass es sichergestellt ist, dass es keine negativen Auswirkungen hat.
Und wenn du von zwei, drei Leuten dann einen Pass schon kriegst, dann checkst du es auch irgendwie ein oder gibt es dann noch mal jemanden, der noch mal sagen darf?
Nein, ich committe dann und in der Commit-Message steht drin, was ich ändere und warum ich es ändere. Und da steht dann aber auch drin OK und dann die Entwickler.
Also alle, die sozusagen gesagt haben, meiner Meinung nach ist das schon prima. Und wenn es dann wirklich irgendwas gebrochen hat, dann kriegen die halt auf den Sack auch. Und du auch.
Aber deswegen testet man ja auch. Und das ist eine der Sachen, die Theo immer wieder sagt. Beim Testen geht es nicht nur darum, wenn ich eine Änderung mache, funktioniert meine Änderung. Sondern hat meine Änderung keinen negativen Impact auf bestehende Funktionalität. Aber das ist häufig das, was Leute übersehen. Es gibt ja ein Treiberunterstützer, der häufig viele verschiedene Devices von dem und dem Hersteller unterstützt. Dazu gehe ich zum Beispiel bei dem Treiber für eine neue Intel-Karte hinzu, mache dafür so ein paar Sachen, dass sie auch wirklich funktionieren, stelle das auch sicher. Ich habe das natürlich hier bei mir getestet. Und dann kommt aber eigentlich von Theo und von anderen Leuten die kritische Frage, ja, aber es ist völlig egal, ob es erstmal bei dir funktioniert. Schau doch erstmal, ob die anderen Karten auch noch alle funktionieren. Und das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, den auch zu verstehen. Natürlich ist es schön, wenn man neue Karten hinzufügt, aber es bringt keinem was, wenn die neue Karte unterstützt ist und zehn alte nicht mehr funktionieren.
Ja, das erinnert mich so an diesen Fuckup, der das Devian-Projekt da vor einiger Zeit hatte, mit dieser Code-Änderung, die dann dazu geführt hat, dass die ganzen Host-Schüssel so eine mangelhafte Sicherheit hatten. Das ist im Prinzip genau so ein Problem gewesen.
Ich denke, gut umschreiben kann man es auch ein bisschen mit dem Satz Evolution, not Revolution. Im Prinzip ist die Entwicklung, die bei OpenBSD passiert, eine evolutionäre, keine revolutionäre. Wir versuchen nicht innerhalb von einem Release alles umzuschmeißen, sondern wir machen alle halbe Jahre ein Release. Das ist so ein bisschen sicher, wie das Arme in der Kirche. Wir haben im November ein Release und im Mai. Das passiert.
Das stellt dann auch sozusagen die Party-Folge sicher.
Ja, also es ist im Prinzip, kann man so ein bisschen überlächeln, aber eigentlich ist es eine ziemlich geniale Sache.
Ich lächle da gar nicht drüber. Das ist ja auch nicht so besonders. Dieses regelmäßige Release-Konzept, das sehe ich an vielen Stellen.
Aber wer hält es ein?
Das habe ich jetzt so nicht überprüft.
Richtig. Und das ist halt so ein bisschen das Spannende. Das wir tatsächlich immer einhalten. Und das macht die Planung zum Beispiel, wenn du wiederum vom kommerziellen Aspekt rangehst. Du hast den Kunden, die musst du patchen, musst du updaten. Und OpenBSD unterstützt die letzten zwei Releases mit Sicherheitsupdates. Das heißt aber, du hast auch ein sehr geniales Fenster, was du kalkulieren kannst mit dem Kunden, was du ihm auch kommunizieren kannst und verkaufen kannst.
Die letzten zwei Releases, also im Prinzip immer nur ein Jahr? Richtig. Das ist aber nicht sehr viel, oder?
Es ist auch nicht viel Arbeit, eine OpenBSD komplett von 4.3. zum Beispiel auf 4.5. Es ist auch nicht viel Arbeit, weil es sind evolutionäre Schritte dazwischen.
Also man ist euer Review-Stell sicher, dass man dann auch keine negativen Auswirkungen hat?
Ich betreibe das jetzt mehr oder weniger arbeitstechnisch seit sechs Jahren. Und es funktioniert eigentlich ziemlich gut. Und ich weiß, es gibt ein paar, mit denen ich mich austausche, die mit OpenBSD an sich mit der Software tatsächlich arbeiten und auch kommerziell arbeiten. Und es funktioniert, finde ich, unheimlich gut. Und es ist vor allem ein leicht verständliches Modell auch für Leute.
Was man vielleicht nochmal erwähnen sollte, auch wenn man das immer so leicht als gegeben voraussetzt, in der BSD-Welt, wenn wir jetzt hier von einer Version sprechen, dann reden wir jetzt nicht wie bei Linux von einer Kernel-Version, sondern wir reden ja von einem vollständigen System.
Ein vollständiges Betriebssystem, so wie dein Windows-CD-Set oder dein Mac OS-CD.
Dazu gehört halt der Kernel, aber dazu gehört auch das ganze User-Land, alle Tools und so weiter. Das heißt, es gibt immer sozusagen ein wohl definiertes Featureset von allem. Und wenn ich jetzt so ein Upgrade mache, dann wird auch alles aktualisiert.
Richtig.
Und das heißt, auch wenn so ein Subsystem sich jetzt komplett geändert hat...
Was für ein Subsystem ändert sich komplett?
Weiß ich nicht. Das Beispiel vorhin mit der Packet Firewall...
Richtig. Das war ein großer Schritt, richtig. Das gab es schon.
Man gibt es dann auch so die passenden Skripte, die dann irgendwie so das Alte nehmen und in die neue Welt automatisch rüberschieben?
Also ich glaube, gerade bei einem Packet Filter ist das kaum zu schaffen. Da musst du ja einen kompletten Parser für das Alte schreiben, der das Neue rausläuft.
Okay, also ganz ohne Pitfalls ist es dann irgendwie jetzt auch nicht. Also man ist schon auch unter einem gewissen Druck jetzt dadurch, dass man sozusagen auf Sicherheitsupdates bei alten Versionen nicht mehr so zählen kann?
Richtig. Man könnte sich aber ja auch backporten, ist ja im Source verfügbar. Das machen wir ja auch.
Ja gut, aber das ist natürlich jetzt für den normalen Administrationsinteressierten vielleicht nicht unbedingt die Option, oder?
Richtig, aber man hat ja natürlich auch ein bisschen Zeit, sich auch vorzubeiden. Gerade wenn man für sich in seiner Umgebung professionell OpenBSD-System hat, aber selbst zu Hause verfolgt man ja so ein bisschen die Szene. Man weiß halt, was auf einen zukommt beim nächsten Release, weil es gibt halt die Dokumentation, es gibt halt eine Seite plus.html auf openbsd.org, wo kontinuierlich drinsteht, was ändert sich gerade bei unserem Betriebssystem. Und es gibt ja genauso, es gibt immer eine Upgrade FAQ von einem Release zum nächsten. Da steht genau drin, welche Schritte muss ich machen, um das Betriebssystem von Version 4.3 auf Version 4.4 zu kriegen. Also es ist halt schon sehr sauber dokumentiert. Und da geben sich auch die Leute sehr viel Mühe. Also es gibt halt zum Beispiel Nick aus den USA, glaube ich, der macht jetzt die ganze FAQ und wer mal in die FAQ reingeguckt hat, das ist einfach ein exzellentes Dokument. Es ist einfach wiederum wie die Manpages. Die FAQ ist einfach nicht umsonst. Also es heißt wirklich häufig auf der Menge, hey, liest mal einfach einmal die FAQ bitte, weil die FAQ erklärt es an vielen Stellen. Es gibt einfach Leute, die geben sich sehr viel Mühe, diese Dokumentation auch aktuell zu halten.
Ich bin beeindruckt, wie viele Namen du sozusagen jetzt aus dem Projekt immer wieder rausgeschossen bekommst. Das spricht so ein bisschen dafür, dass ihr euch irgendwie häufig seht.
Ist das so?
Vielleicht lest ihr euch ja auch nur häufig, aber habt ihr nicht so regelmäßige Entwicklertreffen sogar auch?
Ja, wir haben Hackathons. Einmal im Jahr gibt es den großen Hackathon in Kanada. Da kommen dann wirklich alle zusammen. Für zehn Tage ist es, glaube ich. Beziehungsweise alle, die sich die Zeit nehmen können. Und dann gibt es sogenannte Mini-Hackathons. Also nächste Woche ist zum Beispiel in Basel der N2K9. Das ist der 2009er Netzwerk Hackathon.
Was findet da statt?
Da kommen die Leute zusammen, die im Netzwerkbereich arbeiten. Also TCP-Stack, Routing-Demons, Netzwerk-Demons, Firewall etc. Und die sind da dann, glaube ich, fünf Tage hinterher. Die sitzen alle in einem Raum. Das sind wahrscheinlich so zwölf bis achtzehn Leute. Und können einfach dadurch, dass du halt eben nicht die Distanz hast, sehr produktiv zusammenarbeiten. Und das gibt natürlich ganz andere Synergieeffekte, wenn achtzehn Leute in einem Raum sind. Fünf Tage. Ich glaube, die Mini-Hackathon sind fünf Tage.
Fünf Tage. Und wer organisiert das?
Leute aus der Entwicklerszene. Den macht der Schweizer Marc Bormer, der auch diese NTP-Treiber schreibt, also für die Uhrensachen. Marc Bormer organisiert relativ viel in dem Bereich. Der letzte Mini-Hackathon war in Coimbra in Portugal. Das war der H2K8, der Hardware-Hackathon. Da war ich auch. Da waren halt so die Leute, die Treiber schreiben, sich mit solchen Sachen beschäftigen. Und so gibt es halt diverse jedes Jahr. Auf www.openbsd.org gibt es eine Seite hackathons.html. Da steht so ein bisschen in der Übersicht, welches alles so gab.
Wird das irgendwie gefördert? Die Kosten dafür sind natürlich jetzt nicht gering.
Es gibt seit einiger Zeit die OpenBSD Foundation. Aber es ist schon immer so gewesen, dass Theo und das OpenBSD-Projekt versuchen, engagierten Entwicklern, die nicht die finanziellen Mittel haben, unter die Arme zu greifen. Das ist sowieso so, dass das Hotel für die Zeit bezahlt wird. Und man teilt sich halt ein Zimmer mit anderen.
Von der OpenBSD Foundation?
Früher war das OpenBSD-Projekt. Aber es gibt eine Entity, die sich darum kümmert. Hotel wird bezahlt, zwar kein Luxus-Einzelzimmer, aber man teilt sich meist mit einem anderen Entwickler ein Zimmer. Man kümmert sich selber um seinen Flug. Nur gibt es die Fälle, dass Studenten, die unheimlich engagiert an OpenBSD arbeiten, denen wird geholfen.
Hier sind auch Schwierigkeiten, sich den Flug zu finanzieren.
Da wird dann geguckt, ob man den Flug sponsoren kann. Oder ob man jemanden anders den Flug sponsoren kann. Wenn man sehr engagiert ist und will, kann man da auf jeden Fall hinkommen.
Und wie geht es dann so zu auf dem Hackathon? Wie muss man sich das dann vorstellen? Ist das dann einfach so Coding the Nerds 24-7? Oder ist das eher so wie auf dem Camp mit Opa?
Nein, es ist schon so. Die Hackathons kosten ja tatsächlich Geld. Deswegen ist es schon dafür gedacht, dass man da produktiv ist. Auf der anderen Seite gehört es natürlich zu einem gewissen sozialen Austausch auch dazu. Man hängt sonst immer nur auf dem Mailing-List rum. So kann man sich natürlich auch mal auf die Zeit zusammen schnacken. Aber was auch dazu gehört, ist zum Beispiel, wenn man abends tatsächlich in einer Kneipe sitzt beim Bier, kommen auch relativ viele Ideen. Steckt man Theo und acht solche Leute an einen Tisch und lässt die über ein, zwei technische Themen reden, da kommt auf jeden Fall irgendwas bei Rauswassern umgesetzt. Und das ist schon sehr spannend. Das ist, glaube ich, auch irgendwie...
Habt ihr Theo selber an vielen von diesen Hackesons auch immer teil?
Ja, schon.
Also an vielen?
Relativ, denke ich.
Bei dieser Hardware-Geschichte, wo du warst?
Ja, dabei auch.
Und, was wird dann so an Code erzeugt, so über die fünf Tage?
Also, ist es wirklich jetzt so richtig Code schaffen oder wird da viel reviewt oder Pläne gemacht? Bei Hackesons hast du die Chance, entweder komplett neue Sachen einfach so schnell, so weit voran zu bringen, dass sie dann tatsächlich in Tree aufgenommen werden können. Beziehungsweise, du hast da tatsächlich die Möglichkeit, tatsächlich mal mit anderen Leuten zusammenzuarbeiten und zum Beispiel auch Sachen auszutesten und mal neue Wege zu verfolgen.
Also, ist es mehr so der Start von neuen Sachen als...
Oder tatsächlich das Umsetzen dann. Du hast eine coole Idee und hast dann irgendwie da zum Beispiel zehn Tage Zeit, um sie halt umzusetzen. Zum Beispiel haben wir in Portugal, bzw. Theo und ein paar andere haben da tatsächlich relativ viel an den Netzwerkkartentreibern verändert und an der Art, wie sie halt mit dem Kern interagieren. Und im Kern interagieren. Das war jetzt so eine Geschichte, da hatte er zwei, drei Leute um sich herum und da haben sie halt dann genau an dem Teil gearbeitet, weil er genau die richtigen Leute auch hatte. Also es geht halt wirklich schon darum, da dann auch beim Hackathon nicht für sich alleine zu sitzen und stumpf fünf Tage für sich selbst zu kursen. Sondern es geht halt darum, dass man da die Möglichkeit hat, gerade mit den anderen zu interagieren und an diesen gewissen Themen auch zusammenzuarbeiten.
Du hast vorhin noch erwähnt, dass du, ich glaube, sogar einen Vortrag gehalten hast. Warum ist es cool, irgendwie OpenBSD-Entwickler zu sein?
Nein, das war, also es ging, also ich habe den Vortrag gehalten, OpenBSD Past, Present and Future, und habe da in den ersten 25 Minuten so ein bisschen den Rückblick gegeben auf die letzten paar Jahre und dann auf das Aktuelle und das, wo es so im nächsten Jahr wahrscheinlich hingeht. Und dann, das war der erste Teil vom Tor, und der zweite Teil ging so ein bisschen auf die Entwicklerkultur ein. Und da habe ich mich inspirieren lassen von einem Vortrag, den DLG, einer unserer australischen Entwickler 2006, auf der OpenCon gehalten hat. Die OpenCon ist eine Konferenz, die die letzten fünf Jahre in Venedig stand, immer am ersten Advent, und war so eine reine OpenBSD-Konferenz. Also wirklich, da waren viele Entwickler, aber auch dann viele User und einfach so wirklich nur OpenBSD-Themen und dann auch eins, zwei Veranstaltungen, hatten auch welche mit Tutorials. Und da hat auch die LG 2006 über die Entwicklerkultur ein bisschen was erzählt. Naja, wir haben viele Sachen, davon haben wir tatsächlich mittlerweile schon abgedeckt. Also wir haben halt so ein bisschen die Peer-Review-Geschichte, die Hackathons, dass Theo tatsächlich so ein bisschen auch das Projekt, also nicht nur ein bisschen, das Projekt einfach auch leitet. Und es gibt halt zum Beispiel auch bei uns eben nicht das, was es in anderen Projekten gibt, diese Abstimmen-Orgien, dass es halt irgendwie ein basisdemokratischer Prozess ist, das gibt irgendein Thema, da können irgendwie 100 Entwickler abstimmen, jeder hat eine Stimme dafür und es gibt dann irgendwelche Ämter und all sowas.
So bei Demian zum Beispiel, die das ja zu Perfektion gebracht haben. Genau.
Wie Fiebi ist hier, glaube ich, auch relativ viel Diskussion und nicht diskussion, aber auch viel Abstimmerei. Und der Punkt ist, letztendlich erzeugt man damit aber keinen technologischen Know-how, behaupte ich. Ich bin noch nicht allein, aber durch Abstimmen machst du keinen technischen Fortschritt. Das ist so bla bla bla, aber das bringt das ganze technisch nicht vorwärts.
Jetzt braucht es einen schönen Begriff des benevolent Diktators.
Ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, ob du in dem Fall benevolent lagen darfst, aber es gibt da den Diktator.
Gut meint das ja, oder?
Ja, aber es gehört schon dazu, dass es jemanden gibt, der den Ton angibt und der auch so ein bisschen die Herde da lang prügelt, wo sie hin muss.
Also Theodor Rath ist so ein bisschen der Steve Jobs des OpenBSD-Projektes. Okay, wenn du jetzt Ja sagst, kriegst du Ärger, was? Na ja, ich meine, das ist etwas, was man halt häufig findet. Es gibt unterschiedliche Kulturen, es gibt wirklich Laber- und Konsenskulturen, die können für viele Sachen auch gut funktionieren. Das würde ich jetzt gar nicht schlicht sagen.
Aber ich glaube nicht für eine Entwicklung von einem Betriebssystem.
Ja, das ist eine interessante These an der Stelle. Weil das, du meinst, also dein Punkt ist einfach, es braucht einfach diese Schärfe. Ich meine, was ist, wenn er jetzt morgen vom Bus überfahren wird?
Das habe ich schon ein paar Mal gefragt, ob der OpenBSD dann wo weiter überleben würde. Ich weiß es nicht. Also sicherlich auf irgendeine Art und Weise, aber es wäre nicht mehr das so. Weil er hat einfach einen sehr eigenen Stil. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was OpenBSD auch so prägt. Ich meine, häufig genug kotze ich über seine Art. Also das Ganze muss ich auch so sagen. Es gibt viele Stellen, wo ich wirklich der Meinung bin, so muss man es nicht machen. Auf der anderen Seite sehe ich aber auch, was er alles zustande kriegt. Und dafür ziehe ich auch den Hut. Und was er schon für eine Gemeinschaft eigentlich hat in den OpenBSD-Entwicklern.
Das weiß er aber auch zu schätzen, oder?
Mein Gott, wir sind alle nur Menschen und ich glaube, Menschen haben gewisse Charakterzüge. Aber der Punkt ist, man kann sich ja immer aussuchen, mit wem man interagieren möchte und mit wem nicht. Das ist ja letztendlich so eine Sache, die kann man für sich selber ja auch entscheiden. Und in dem Fall, ich finde es halt, ich hänge gerne bei den OpenBSD-Leuten herum. Und ich finde es einfach gut, dass er es tatsächlich schafft, dass wir als relativ kleine Gruppe doch ein sehr fortschrittliches Betriebssystem entwickeln. Und das ist auf jeden Fall eine Leistung.
Was würdest du denn sagen, sind so die wesentlichen Punkte, warum man sich für OpenBSD interessieren sollte, wenn man jetzt, sagen wir mal...
Wir haben coole T-Shirts.
Ja, das war natürlich jetzt ein erschlagendes Argument.
Guck dir meinen Schrank an. Also was ich alles an OpenBSD-T-Shirts und meinem Schrank habe. Mein Mitbewohner, wenn ich einmal komplett einmal alles so wasche, ist erstmal irgendwie drei Wochen lang Wäschelein voll.
Gut, aber sagen wir mal aus Nutzer-Sicht haben wir es jetzt eigentlich schon mal betrachtet. Es gibt halt ein security-orientiertes Betriebssystem, was out of the box eine ganze Menge Dinge mit sich bringt, um eben insbesondere im Netzwerkbereich sichere Systeme zu bauen. Das sage ich jetzt mal so, ist so die Spezialisierung. Liegt sicherlich nicht irgendwie im Fallzahlerbereich, liegt auch nicht auf dem Desktop oder auf dem Laptop, aber das ist das. Der Embedded-Bereich denke ich mal ist auch relativ stark, insbesondere durch diese Wildestriver-Geschichte. Also ich sehe häufiger OpenBSD-Systeme auf so kleinen Böckschen. Da gibt es ja auch diese lustigen Circus-Boxen, die sind ja sehr populär. Gut, das ist sozusagen jetzt die Anwender-Seite. Wenn man jetzt Lust hat zu entwickeln, was ist denn so der beste Weg mit OpenBSD da in die Geschmacksrichtung aufzunehmen?
Wenn man Lust hat, was zu entwickeln? Einfach an der Betriebs-Stimmung zu fuschen oder?
Keine Ahnung, ja fuschen oder die Sachen nach vorne zu bringen, keine Ahnung. Also ich würde behaupten, ich wollte darauf hinaus, wo soll man sozusagen anklopfen? Also wenn jetzt sozusagen jemand Lust hat, sich technisch einzubringen?
Okay, also der beste Weg ist, würde ich sagen, zum einen haben wir ein öffentliches Bug-Tracking, wo immer offene Bugs sind. Das heißt, wenn ich tatsächlich interessiert bin, irgendwie OpenBSD voranzutreiben, gucke ich natürlich, da sind da Bugs, die ich fixen kann. Der Klassiker ist ja eigentlich eher so, ich habe OpenBSD installiert und stelle fest, irgendwas in meinem Laptop, auf meinem Desktop, an meinem Server funktioniert nicht. Also ein Gerät. Das ist ja auch so der Klassiker. Also ich bin damals so, bin ich dann tatsächlich vom Anwender, Administrator, jemand, der beruflich einsetzt, zum Entwickler geworden, weil ich halt eine UMTS-Karte nicht funktioniert hatte. Und die habe ich halt zum Laufen gebracht und so. Das war halt der Weg. Und das ist halt so ein klassischer Weg. Man hat halt irgendwie Hardware, die nicht richtig funktioniert. Man findet einen Bug im System. Also ich benutze es und stelle fest, oh, das funktioniert nicht richtig. Dann mache ich es nochmal heile. Und dann schicke ich einen Diff. Das ist ja so der nächste Schritt, dass man sagt, okay, ich habe einen Bug. Ich fixe ihn und was mache ich dann? Ich schicke einen Diff. Den Diff schickt man normalerweise dann an die Tech-Mailing-Liste, techatopenbsd.org. Und da gucken sich dann OpenBSD-Leute das an und dann kriegt man irgendwie Feedback. Und das ist, denke ich, mal so der klassische Weg. Dann gibt es verschiedene Leute, zum Beispiel Art. Art ist ein Schwede. Der hatte früher, ich glaube, er hatte immer noch so eine öffentliche To-do-Liste, was aus seiner Sicht an OpenBSD immer gefixt werden müsste. Das ist auch ein Klassiker. Da sind auch schon viele Leute darüber ins Projekt gekommen. Ich meine, wenn man sich so ein Projekt anguckt, es gibt immer irgendwas, was man daran besser machen kann. Es gibt vielleicht auch selber Ideen, die man gerne mal bei sich denkt. Gerade wenn man zum Beispiel Informatik studiert und Betriebssysteme-Vorlesungen hat, findet man gerade Sachen, die man gerne in seinem eigenen Betriebssystem sehen würde. Da kann man ja auch einfach mal anfangen, es zu bauen.
Es ist besonders, wenn es natürlich sicherheitsrelevante Aspekte abdeckt. Man dürfte das Interesse besonders groß sein. Das will ich euch jetzt nicht so festnageln auf dieses Security-Ding, aber es ist ja ganz klar, das heißt es.
Das haben wir ja nun selbst als Slogan. Das sind so die Wege, wie man da eigentlich rangeht. Der eher nicht so der beste Weg ist diese klassische Frage auf dem Englischen, wo kann ich denn anfangen zu helfen? Ich suche dir einfach eine Stelle, so ich denke, wenn man Interesse hat, findet man einfach genug.
Und so an öffentlichen...
Ports ist auch noch eine gute Variante. Ich stelle mich schon mal leise in den Wortfall, aber das wäre auch ein sehr wichtiger Punkt.
Ja, ist sowieso noch ein interessanter Punkt, den ich ganz vergessen hatte.
Genau, also im Prinzip ist ja, wir hatten ja vorhin, dass ein OpenBSD-Release ein komplettes Betriebssystem besteht und ein Betriebssystem besteht natürlich nicht nur aus dem Barsystem, sondern auch aus diversen Applikationen, die man ja sonst, zum Beispiel von Linux, kommt auch aus einem Linux-Desktop kennt. Also zum Beispiel, ich fange an bei so was wie MPG, 321, XMS, M-Player, VLC, Firefox, Opera... Genau, you name it. Und das alles ist natürlich nicht Bestandteil des Basisbetriebssystems von OpenBSD, sondern das kommt aus den sogenannten Packages und Ports. Packages sind ja die Binärpakete, die man installieren kann und die werden aus dem sogenannten Port-System gebaut.
Ist das dasselbe Port-System, was auch bei den anderen BSDs zum Einsatz kommt?
Die Basis ist die gleiche. Aber es ist halt Jordan Hubbard, der mittlerweile ja bei Apple relativ weit hoch die Karriereleiter gefallen ist, war ja ursprünglich mal FreeBSD, hat ja FreeBSD ja mit aufgezogen und hat das Port-Framework damals da geschrieben. Davon wurde Mark SP inspiriert, das gab es auch ursprünglich bei OpenBSD und mittlerweile ist das Port-System komplette Rewrite, also das Framework für das Port-Bauen.
Innerhalb von OpenBSD?
Innerhalb, ja. Und die Ports an sich sind BSD-spezifisch, also jedes BSD hat sein Ports-Tree, aber das ist nichts, was irgendwie zusammenhängt. Und was jedoch gemacht wird, natürlich wenn ich eine Applikation portiere, irgendwie von Linux nach OpenBSD für den Ports-Tree, dann gucke ich natürlich, gibt es den Port schon bei FreeBSD, was haben die eigentlich für Patches gebraucht, damit sie es auf eine BSD zum Laufen kriegen. Aber da ist auch das OpenBSD-Ports-System eigentlich so das, wo ich behaupte, dass es die beste Qualität hat. Wir haben sicherlich nicht die meisten Ports, aber...
Woran drückt sich diese Qualität aus?
Dass einfach du im Prinzip, also die Sachen, die du hast, die funktionieren. Ich bin halt relativ häufig, als ich mit FreeBSD in der Ecke geguckt habe, so auf den Schnauze gefallen und habe bei OpenBSD das Gefühl, wir haben zwar nicht immer die neuesten Versionen, aber das, was es als Pakete gibt, funktioniert dann auch. Das ist aber natürlich immer ein sehr subjektives Gefühl auch.
Naja, will ich wohl meinen. Ich meine, was...
Richtig, ja. Aber es geht ja auch so ein bisschen darum, mich jetzt hier die starke Seite von OpenBSD zu betonen. Also behaupte ich ja immer so, wir haben auf jeden Fall die beste Qualität. Und auf jeden Fall ist das natürlich auch ein...
Also du bist zumindest, sagen wir mal, jetzt mit der Port-Qualität bei der Nutzung von OpenBSD zufrieden. Also du hast den Eindruck, dass, wenn du jetzt das Port-System benutzt und irgendwas installieren lässt, du eine relativ niedrige Fehlerrate hast.
Ja, aber einer meiner engeren Freunde gehört ja auch zu den Leuten, die ein Port-System ständig aufbauen.
Also das heißt, du darfst gar nichts dagegen sagen. Sonst gibt es Community-Strafe.
Richtig. Naja, und das ist immer ein guter Weg, um sich auch einzubringen. Weil das ist nämlich auch der Klassiker, dass man nämlich, wie der eine von denen, wie man eigentlich zu sowas kommt, dass man sagt, hey, jetzt habe ich mir OpenBSD installiert, jetzt habe ich so die Applikation, die ich sonst habe. Aber meine Lieblingsapplikation, die gibt es noch nicht als OpenBSD-Paket.
An damit.
Richtig. Und das ist natürlich auch so ein sehr guter Weg zu helfen, einfach weil das ist das, was auch anderen Leuten hilft, wiederum.
Das ist auch aus meiner Erfahrung, ich habe wenig damit gemacht, aber ich habe mich hier und da auch mal um Ports gekümmert. Das ist auch ein guter Weg, um die Spezifiker eines Betriebssystems kennenzulernen, weil es genau darum geht.
Und da sind wir uns auch damals zum ersten Mal über den Weg gelaufen, lieber Tim, bei Davin Ports, da hattest du nämlich zwei, drei Ports vermittelt und ich habe dich kummeltet, weil ich habe mich ja früher Davin Ports gemacht. Da haben wir nämlich das erste Mal Kontakt gehabt.
Lang ist's her. Aber damit machst du nichts mehr mit Davin, oder? Gar nicht mehr.
Da hat sich etwas zerschieden mit Apple 2005. Aber das ist wie gesagt nicht Bestandteil von OpenBSD und das kann man auch auf meiner Webseite nachlesen, da muss man jetzt nicht weiter ins Detail gehen.
Ja, was ist vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen was zu dem aktuellen Stand der Dinge? Also was ist denn das aktuelle Release gerade?
4.4.
4.4. Und man kann jetzt davon ausgehen, dieses Jahr wird es zwei weitere Releases geben.
1. Mai 4.5.
Und was ist denn so der Umfang der Änderungen? Also ich meine, ist das jetzt nur so 50 Zeilen Text, wo drin steht, wir haben hier ein bisschen was geändert, da ein bisschen was geändert? Oder ist es wirklich so von Release zu Release, gibt es da immer so signifikante Schritte?
Ich habe mich früher mit Bernhard unterhalten, weil ich mir sicher war, dass wir diese Frage stellen müssen. Wir haben mal versucht, auf dem Weg zur Wohnung zu überlegen, was es eigentlich so an Änderungen gab. Weil es ist schon ganz schön schwer, aus dem aktuellen Hirn einfach so abzurufen. Einer der Sachen, woran Mark Ketennis, auch einer der Holländer, und der, der im Spark-64-Bereich auch Support für die ganzen neueren Suns geschrieben hat, arbeitet gerade an der... Es gibt bei großen Suns diese ganzen Unterteilungen in verschiedene Zonen oder irgendwie was. Der arbeitet gerade an dem Support für diese Zonen, sodass man tatsächlich auch auf diesen riesengroßen Sun-Server-Systemen OpenBSD überall fahren kann. Das wird er wohl auch schaffen bis 45. Dann wird es wohl tatsächlich, während wir in Coimbra waren, beim Hardware-Casone im November, auf das OpenMoco portiert. Noch nicht komplett, also es ist noch nicht wirklich in einem...
Also auf das Gerät, auf den Free Runner meinst du?
Ja, genau, auf den Free Runner, genau.
Weil OpenMoco ist ja sozusagen die Software.
Ich meine auf den Free Runner, pardon. Es ist natürlich noch nicht in dem Zustand, dass man damit irgendwie sinnvoll was machen kann, aber es bootet und man sieht es booten und es ist ansprechbar.
Man kann auch dann schon telefonieren?
Ich sagte, man kann es nicht sinnvoll benutzen. Telefonieren kann man auch nicht sinnvoll damit mit unter OpenMoco, aber das ist meine Persönlichkeit. Ich habe eins und ich habe es versucht und es geht nur manchmal so. Aber auf jeden Fall, das ist was, was auch irgendwie passiert ist. Dann wie gesagt jede Menge Änderungen im Netzwerkbereich, das was in Coimbra auch gemacht wurde, was sich denke ich mal auch auf die Performance im Netzwerkdurchsatz auswirken wird. Was hatten wir vorhin noch gesagt?
Wie sieht denn das mit den aktuellen, wir haben es vorhin schon ein bisschen angesprochen.
desktop, eine neue Version von GNOME wird enthalten sein. Da arbeiten Jasper und Antoine, also ein Franzose und ein Holländer, sehr aktiv dran. Also Jasper ist auch einer von den sehr, sehr aktiven Portsleuten. Die arbeiten im Augenblick daran, dass sie ein aktuelles GNOME bereitstellen, was natürlich, wir hatten es vorhin, Desktop ist nicht ganz so die Stärke, was natürlich dann auch mal wieder richtig schön ist, dass man ein aktuelles GNOME dabei hat. Aber wirklich, ich hab dich unterbrochen, tut mir leid.
Ja, nee, macht ja nichts. Ich meine, gerade jetzt im Betriebssystembereich haben wir nun zwei, also ich sehe, dass derzeit in der PC-Technologie gibt es einfach derzeit zwei wesentliche Umbrüche, worauf die Betriebssysteme reagieren müssen. Das eine ist 64-Bit und das andere ist Multicore.
Richtig.
Also man hat es jetzt in zunehmendem Maße mit Multiprozessorsystemen zu tun, einfach weil...
In zunehmendem Maße kannst du noch irgendwo... Wo kaufst du ein Single-Core-System?
Klar, naja gut, ich meine im Embedded-Bereich oder so.
Ja, da noch, aber sonst, Abseits des Servers geht gar nicht mehr. Notebooks, welches Notebook ist im Augenblick noch Single-Core?
Aber sagen wir mal, wenn es zwei Cores sind, dann ist es vielleicht noch zu verkraften, wenn man das nicht besonders gut unterstützt. Aber in zunehmendem Maße, wenn wir das wahrscheinlich mit 8, 16, 32 und was weiß ich, wie viele Cores noch rumschlagen müssen, wie sieht es denn da bei OpenBSD aus? Wenn ich schon so höre, nicht so Re-Entranter-Könnel, ist das natürlich eine Frage, die ich stellen muss.
Also Dual-Core geht problemlos, also FNP ist auch kein Problem. Natürlich ist die Frage, wie viel Nutzen es hat. Man merkt den Unterschied zwischen Single-Core und Dual-Core auf jeden Fall. Auch Multiprozesse, man steht gerade zum Beispiel bei einem Web-Server, bei einer Firewall macht es überhaupt keinen Sinn. Da siehst du nicht mal irgendwie was. Bei der zweiten CPU läuft fast nur Alde, wenn du wirklich eine normale Firewall hast.
Weil die so schnell ist?
Was machst du auf einer Firewall, wenn nicht der Colonel es unterstützt, dass du zum Beispiel ständig auf beiden CPUs zum Beispiel das Packet-Filtering machst? Das könnte er ja unterstützen. Richtig, aber das tun wir nicht. Ja, aber soweit ich zumindest weiß. Was zum Beispiel eine Möglichkeit wäre, wo die OpenBSD die entsprechenden Leute benagt hat, ist, wenn du IPSEC-Endpunkte hast und du hast eine Multi-Core-Maschine, dass du zum Beispiel die anderen Cores als mathematische Co-Prozessoren einsetzt, um noch schneller verschlüsseln zu können. Das sind so Modelle, wo man zum Beispiel dann gut ansetzen könnte, aber das wird im Augenblick nicht unterstützt. Ich weiß gar nicht, was so die Maximalanzahl an CPUs ist, die wir zum Beispiel auf Spark 64 unterstützen. Ich meine, das ist 1632 sogar.
Aber grundsätzlich ist es sozusagen Multi-Core und mehr Prozessorsupport ist vorhanden.
Auf gewissen Architekturen. Also Mac-Powered-PC, Spark 64, i3-86, AMD 64 sind glaube ich diejenigen, die wir auch nicht unterstützen.
Für Multi-Core.
Also nicht Multi-Core, Multi-Prozessor. Ich meine, Multi-Core ist ja auch gleich heraus.
Es gibt Unterschiede mit Caching und so. Okay, aber so tief müssen wir jetzt auch gar nicht graben. Und welche Plattformen werden denn überhaupt unterstützt? Also wie weit ist denn OpenBSD so portiert? Wird das nicht fast nur auf PCs eingesetzt?
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Also der Vollständigkeit ist halt auf openbsd.org zu gucken, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall Alphaports, Mac-Power-PC, Mac 68K.
Alte Scheiße.
Ich bin der Meinung, ihr müsst solche Dinge nur noch wegschmeißen, viel zu viel Strom fressen und nichts taugen. Spark, Spark 64, Zaurus, kennt auch jeder, der auf den CCC-Events war, vom Stand von Wim, diese kleinen Zaurusse, die mit OpenBSD laufen. Also diverse so. Anders als NetBSD versuchen wir nicht, jede Hardware unterm Himmel so zu unterstützen, aber wir machen natürlich auch kein Crosscom-Pilot. Anders als NetBSD, die zwar irgendwie crosscomputieren können, aber dann auf der eigentlichen Altitude nicht mehr richtig laufen. Aber wir unterstützen schon so diverse Architekturen. Es gibt auch welche, die wurden mit der Zeit weggeräumt, weil sie nicht mehr gebraucht wurden. Also es wurden auch Ports einfach abgekündigt für gewisse Architekturen. Aber so die Standards unterstützen wir eigentlich alle. Gerade so Alfa und so auch noch.
Was ist so mit dem, so der zweite große Punkt neben Multi-Core, Multi-Prozessor sehe ich, ist halt die Transition auf 64-Bit. Bist du die schon irgendwie abgeschlossen?
Ja, was heißt Transition auf 64-Bit? Also ich meine, Spark 64 ist von Haus aus die ganze Zeit 64-Bit gewesen. Das unterstützen wir auch. Also die Frage ist halt, in welchen Subsystemen du immer 64-Bit hast. Wir haben es jetzt bei UFS2 natürlich. UFS2 ist ein 64-bitiges Dateisystem. Da ist natürlich die Frage, die ich mir manchmal stelle, warum hat man überhaupt den Schritt gemacht und ist nicht leicht mit 128-bitiges gegangen. Aber das sind dann so Detailfragen.
Du meinst jetzt, was die Adressierung des Speicherplatzes betrifft. Ich rede jetzt im Wesentlichen von 64-Bit-Adressierung. Da unterhält er auch der 64-bit Instruktionssatz jetzt auf PC-Prozessoren. Genau, die AMD64-Plattform. Ja, genau.
Das unterstützen wir. Also das, was natürlich auffällt, was noch nicht läuft unter AMD64 ist, meine ich die Linux-Emulation. Weil das natürlich ein Teil des Videos, auch gewisse Programme, die es nicht im Source-Code verfügbar gibt für OpenBSD, also die nicht im Source verfügbar sind. Da ist zum Beispiel Opera. Opera gibt es natürlich als Browser für Linux. Den kannst du in der Linux-Emulation laufen lassen.
Ah ja, aber das läuft doch nicht in der 64-Bit-Lang.
Das läuft nicht auf AMD64. Solche Sachen gibt es natürlich. Aber ansonsten, also AMD64 läuft und Spark64 auch. MIPS ist glaube ich auch 64-Bit, also das unterstützen wir auch.
Gut, dann ist die Zukunft ja schon da. Super. Haben wir was Wichtiges vergessen? Was stehen so in diesem Jahr an interessanten Veranstaltungen an? Ich nehme an, ihr werdet alle wahrscheinlich wieder in Holland auflaufen.
Selbstverständlich. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall natürlich jetzt, steht vor der Haustür, Foste. Da ist OpenBSD-Stand.
Das ist immer im Februar, das ist in Brüssel, in den kalten zugegen Hallen.
Richtig, genau. Ist aber ansonsten eigentlich ein wirklich schöner Event, weil er sehr communityorientiert ist.
Das stimmt, sehr viele Entwickler. Aber man sollte sich auf jeden Fall gut warm anziehen.
Ich werde auch jedes Jahr krank zur Foste, deswegen fahre ich nicht mehr hin.
Ich wundere mich auch, wie die Leute das schaffen. Ich war da irgendwie zwei, drei Mal und es ist was Zugigeres, wenn man das mindestens mal im Juni machen würde oder so.
Also ja, es gibt halt Haar als großen Event, denke ich mal, dieses Jahr.
Hacking at random, das Camp der Holländer.
13. bis 16. August. Jawoll, BSD Village wird es auch geben. Wim und ich organisieren das, wie die letzten Male. Was gibt es denn da noch so an?
Dem kann man sich anschließen, wenn man möchte.
Richtig, da gibt es dann auch eine Webseite zu. Da kann man sich vorher anmelden und dann organisieren, wer das alles ist. Ich überlege halt, was es noch so an Events gibt.
Es gibt doch da in der Schweiz auch immer so eine BSD-Konferenz, oder?
Da gab es die Euro-BSD-Konferenz. Die wandert aber jedes Jahr, dieses Jahr ist sie in England und ich meine, eurobsd.org, für die, die nachgucken wollen, ist auf jeden Fall eine der BSD-Konferenzen, also nicht OpenBSD, sondern wirklich BSD-lastig dann.
Und dann gibt es diese Sache in Venedig.
Richtig, wobei es nicht klar ist, ob es die dieses Jahr in Venedig geben wird oder ob sie woanders stattfindet, es kann sein, dass es aus diversen organisatorischen Gründen mal irgendwo anders hinverlagert wird. Aber OpenCon war sonst auch immer wirklich gut und auch zu empfehlen. Und natürlich der Kongress.
Der Kongress immer. Der spielt eine große Rolle für euch?
Ja, für mich persönlich spielt der Kongress eine große Rolle, weil es mein Weihnachtstag ist.
Ich meine, ich weiß, dass OpenBSD da auch mal sehr präsent ist, aber was bringt der Kongress dem Projekt?
Publicity, aber auch einfach das Ende des Jahres mit einer Menge Gleichgesinnte zu verbringen und einfach da auch mal so ein bisschen zu entspannen und halt einfach, aber viele Leute...
Aber ich meine, gibt es da auch nennenswerte neue Kontakte? Ist das so irgendwie ein Ort, um Leute an OpenBSD heranzuführen?
Wahrscheinlich, also ich weiß nicht genau, weil ich ja im Prinzip... Schwer zu sagen, ne? Ja, wenn man über die Jahre dabei ist, dann natürlich gibt's halt immer Leute, die infizieren werden überall, also ob das nun Camp ist, Congress oder irgendwelche anderen Messen. Die Leute, da euch das halt wimm, sich immer so den Arsch aufreißt und überall ist, kannst ja schwer sagen, von welcher Veranstaltung kommen die Leute wirklich. Aber es ist natürlich das Congress so eine der Sachen, wo man natürlich viel mit den Leuten in das Gespräch kommt, gerade weil man halt eben nicht nur zwei Tage wie bei manchen Wochenendenkonferenzen, sondern man hat halt relativ lange Zeit und dann kommt es halt auch vor, dass man sich mal häufiger über den Weg läuft und ein bisschen mehr schlagt oder dass sich tatsächlich Leute, das haben wir beim Congress auch, Leute mit ihren Problemen an den Tisch kommen und sagen, hier könnt ihr das fixen. Der Standard ist natürlich, hey, erstmal drei, vier Bier und dann gucken wir weiter.
Ich sage nur Humpa. Das müssen wir vielleicht noch mal als letztes aufklären. Wo kommt denn diese Affinität her zu diesem Humpa-Phänomen?
Du redest leider mit dem falschen. Ja, weil ich hasse diesen Humpa-Wahn. Also mir persönlich geht er furchtbar auf den Senkel, aber erklären kann ich es trotzdem. Es gibt eine Band, ich glaube, die kommt aus Finnland, die nennt sich Elekke Lazy.
Elekke Lazy.
Ja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, die covern berühmte Lieder und singen sie halt dann auf Finnisch, also zum Beispiel was ich Final Countdown und was hast du nicht gesehen. Ich habe jetzt schon zig Sachen gemacht. Und da gibt es halt immer wieder dieses Wort Humpa drin. Und das Ganze begann sich zu der Zeit des, ich weiß gar nicht, es fing irgendwann auf irgendeinem Heckeshorn an, ursprünglich. Und auf jeden Fall so richtig populär und so, dass es alle genervt hat, war dann das Camp 2003. Wo dann so ein paar Spezialisten dann tatsächlich, also letztendlich sind ein paar Leute, die Tag und Nacht über das Camp gezogen haben, nur Humpa gerufen. Aber auch ohne, das war dann ohne irgendwelche Assoziationen zur OpenBSD. Die haben es halt bei uns aufgegriffen und dann wurde es so zelebriert. Aber seitdem ist es halt irgendwie präsent und hängt auch an uns irgendwie dran, so.
Obwohl es eigentlich gar nicht so gut ist.
Weiß ich nicht, also ich bin da auch, weiß ich nicht, es ist halt ganz spaßig für einen Abend, aber dann ist es auch mal wieder gut. Die Musik ist doch einfach auf Dauer nervtönt.
Das ist wirklich großartig. Wer das nicht kennt, muss unbedingt mal reinhören. Der Leckedehse, ich habe jetzt keine Ahnung, wie man es genau schreibt, steht auf jeden Fall in den Links, ist irgendwie sehr Finnish, ist halt so polka und verrücktes Zeug. Hat aber auf jeden Fall einen großen Kultfaktor und eine Menge Devote-Anhänger, das kann man auf jeden Fall sagen. Na gut, das will ich euch gar nicht anhängen. Ja, Felix, haben wir es? Fällt dir noch etwas Wichtiges ein, was ich vergessen habe? Super. Na dann, sage ich vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zum Projekt OpenBSD. Haben wir das jetzt endlich auch im Kasten nach einem anderthalb Jahr. Mal gucken. Hier geht es dann auch bald wieder weiter. Ich bin gerade auf Podcast-Reise im deutschen Nordwesten.
Im Ammerland. Ammerland ist abgebrannt. Aber so ungefähr. Ich glaube, das ist hier oben Ammerland.
Genau. Das heißt, auch die nächste Sendung wird hoffentlich, so sehen wir sie nicht dann noch im letzten Moment, aus den Händengeräten hier aus der Region kommen. Aber wie immer, verrate ich nicht, worum es geht, damit die Spannung erhalten bleibt, hier bei Chaosradio Express. Und ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören. Zuletzt wiederholte, wie immer, Kommentare sehr erbeten in dem Blog-Eintrag zu dieser Sendung oder wenn ihr was nicht ganz so öffentliches zu kommentieren habt, dann vielleicht auch als E-Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de. Und dann sage ich noch Tschüss und viel Spaß bei Chaosradio Express.